welcome welcome everybody it is monday
august 8th a beautiful summer day
[Music]
it's h3tv and we are vibing out we have
such an action-packed show here today
thank you everyone for being here
sponsored by uh hello fresh and stamps
hello fresh guys
are you looking for a stress free summer
hellofresh send you foolproof
step-by-step recipes and fresh
pre-portioned ingredients to make meal
time a summer breeze
get 16 free meals plus three gifts with
code h3tv 16.
oh hellofresh.com
h3 tv 16 use the code h3tv h3tv16 thank
you thank you hellofresh we love them
you know i'm
the fruper troopers all ride for
hellofresh thank you all right what a
show uh we've got today you know we had
geez we had
two do we have two interviews last week
uh well there was the bff's podcast
right so we had two
guest episodes we have like a week of uh
stories
built up man and i'm like
ready to go
and as the title suggests
i know that i've been all peace and love
lately but today it's time for war
[Music]
blow that horn
low and hard baby and just because i've
softened on some of my
you know just because i've softened on
some people doesn't mean
i've changed
well in a well
i have changed
but only in some way they they deserve
it right more focused
these people have it coming big time
[Music]
soldiers
man yourselves
we shall invade wikifeet.com
we shall visit does ryan kavanaugh look
like harvey weinstein
via google
we shall
uh
[Music]
we shall
clash
on the fields of valhalla man the
barricades that's literal that's quite
literal
we shall clash on the fields of valhalla
we shall cry at pinocchio
like jordan peterson
i don't know
yeah we got a lot to talk about i've got
so many beefs so many axes to grind
you know got one with bobby lee i got
one with
abey who's calling in he's on vacation
right now he's calling in
a little bit i got one with david pork
boy who i tried to bury the hatchet with
but now he's just straight lying to on
me bro and i got receipts that's right
david
mr pork
aydah ross came for love bro and that's
[ __ ] i already didn't dude i already
didn't like that little [ __ ]
it's on site [ __ ]
ninja is actually uh
ninja is dear and loved so we're just
gonna give him a shout out
shout out
alex jones lawsuit i've been itching to
talk about this holy [ __ ]
actually i'm here to support tana mojo
today too
riding for my new besties
so much to talk about but first let's
talk about i would say behind
all oliver bobby's probably the most
hated person in my life
they're one until a close neck and neck
look at this [ __ ]
after the after everything with the
howie mandel angles
then bobby lee hit me with this shot i
mean who does that
who who sets this shot up like this
and i just got to say if you go to tiger
belly
their podcast i've been trying
is this the new one yeah
uh
who does this look at their sh what what
kind of like
schizophrenic and you know not to demean
our our uh neurodivergent kings but like
who can look at all these shots there's
four different [ __ ] shots you ever
heard of a live switcher i don't i have
two eyes not four dude
right
back me up
it's ridiculous and that this shot
definitely doesn't need to be there this
one on the bottom left like who we don't
need this
that adds nothing
and then look at this [ __ ] guy look
like humpty dumpty with the [ __ ] eggs
and with arms and legs bro about to take
a spill
danced my horseman my king's horseman
yeah i've tried to put you back together
again but
unfortunately
it's not successful can you believe this
[ __ ] anyway i kind of like it
you like that
it's kind of a vibe i don't know dude
it's insane
didn't we do that once we're on the show
where we like kind of did it as a as a
gag where we had like a grid of all good
back
but not as a serious podcast
[Laughter]
you know what i mean you have to have
like split you have to have like four
different split personalities to watch
this all the same time
you have to have three homies where
everyone watches one box and then comes
through right
notes
i don't know my super brain kind of
likes it sumo adhd brain
oh my god
i watch all of them at once
me too this shot is unforgivable
so anyway bobby [ __ ] me big time
[Laughter]
hate him
this shot's been going around the
internet
funny people been actually unironically
fat shaming me
on twitter for this
there was a tweet that has just like 30
000 likes of people just fat shaming me
like unironically
shame it's awesome shame
it's embarrassing for them
you're like in on the joke too like you
know that i posted the photo i the only
reason
literally i posted it yeah that's why
they have it
but okay that happens that's something
that happens like to me all the time
i post [ __ ]
that makes me look dumb or fat or ugly
or whatever and then people go
look at this fat ugly egg
what a [ __ ] clown
so fat ratio
fat loser
yeah
look here's the deal
all right yeah all right joe even even
our president is fat shaming there's no
time there's no escape from a damn our
thumbnail goes hard today
shut up cam
got a cam grant
[Applause]
um
speaking of well here we got a bunch of
memes now so eat your heart out so that
here's me and howie's
and then me and bobby i mean which one's
worse this is why i don't do other
people's podcasts oh all right
oh that's so good yeah and the title is
it's so sweet and heartwarming to see
ethan taking theodore on other podcasts
what do we do about it it looks like i
gained like 20 pounds by the way between
the weeks
is it altered like
i got you got a little bit of
hassan head going on in this picture
because it's all distorted bro it looks
so tiny the whole thing is [ __ ]
distorted and psychotic
[Laughter]
it's just not a flattering angle you
can't do your guess like that by the way
since
i guess i should mention just a little
teaser for thursday
we are going to get to the bottom of
this
we're doing phrenology this thursday
on uh
on leftovers i got oh dude wait hassan
doesn't know he's gonna know now though
yeah well we mentioned it we said we
didn't do that on the way so hassan my
co-host for leftovers on thursday
there's a meme about him having a tiny
head so we got
we got the official measuring tool we're
gonna measure his dome yep
and get to the bottom of this
once and for all
but anyway so me and theodore
uh an elegant icon but wait that's
edited right
like what the [ __ ]
you don't yeah i think it's interesting
well i don't know because it is a crazy
photo anyway that's what i'm saying it
was all kind of crazy to begin with
ethan looking real comfortable again on
tiger valley
and well they get the couch that gave me
so reclining you can't even lift up on
it you can tell it's a it's a deep couch
i was set up dude
well does everybody look like that on
his show can we look at something yeah
you want you want to cross check it yeah
let's see
here i am the creation of ethan of
course
the two bad shots merging uh to create
uh oh that's powerful a sentient mind
sentient beauty full of mind oh
oh there's the egg okay
that's just not funny that's just too
far does anyone know when ela is
dropping the sick garfield collab
that's [ __ ] up whoever made that shame
on you
shane
wait shane
you got something good dan
oh my god no i just looked at a recent
not the schizo cam
can you add in my monitor as well so
that when i pull stuff up that can just
instantly be on there
um
here's a no yes he set me up he's on a
chair
he set me the [ __ ] up look how they have
the same chair they're on equal footing
two equals he puts my ass on the
recliner with the freak angle
oh my god bobby that's what i'm saying
he he's a close second to oliver but
that man
that man is
not he's just a piece of [ __ ] dude
so true
um
anyway let's keep going ethan on the set
a tiger now that one's edited right
i don't well that that one has to be
edited
i think it just is a little bit lens
distortion maybe
something like that for sure
here i am skateboarding cheers thank you
you look [ __ ] sick yeah thank you for
that
riding a dinosaur oh
it's too far you guys no these are cool
man these are compliments
ryan and [ __ ] t-rex
actually there was one
moment on tiger belly that i'm super
proud of
maybe can someone pull it it's the one
where uh
the post is something like ethan can't
help himself or something
we were talking about relationships and
you know bobby and kalila broke up and i
burned him so [ __ ] good
[Music]
well mean but i guess so is the angle so
all right so we just doing the whole
show this way guys is this the but is
this you're missing an angle where you
can see how [ __ ] fat
that's the only thing here i'll work on
that yeah can you add that please
yeah
we need a side profile please yeah aby's
not here just use his camera
oh thank you so much to
av said i could sit here for the week
i'm not stealing it
i'm not saying shout out analia who
donated a hundred thank you queen treat
yourself kings and
queens giving back to the podcast that
has helped me through an extremely hard
past couple weeks well thank you so much
i'm glad to be there uh with you we love
you here's the clip but i use that pain
and suffering you know watch this [ __ ]
this is what bobby gets for this
[ __ ]
ready
no no i can't do this i gotta i will
show them
i will show the world
right that this is legit
you know something else though
i'll say to someone like that because if
i was single
and struggling to find a significant
other which is really important in life
to feeling confident and fulfilled and
healthy and stuff
like you used to have
oh god i don't know why i did that i'm
sorry
why do you do that it was so natural for
you yeah like why do you like stuff
because i felt like
because i felt like that's what you were
thinking and so i wasn't thinking i was
like i don't want him to think that i'm
insulting him and so then i do
yeah
i had to take it i took the chance and i
got him [ __ ] good and he deserves it
you know what it gives
i don't know why i said he was divorced
i don't know why i said he was divorced
when you were at howie's when you were
talking about ryan kavanaugh
you were like and he's different oh
no yeah yeah yeah well because the
reason i by the way i don't know if we
ever talked about that we did yeah i was
like you ca i don't want to misspeak
when it comes to i don't know
but it's funny the top comment is the
intrusive thoughts one again yeah
kind of
but i use that pain and suffering i go
you know no i can't do that yeah
anyway bobby lee shame on you
god i got this bug bite that's killing
me shame
shame
by the way also
what we talked about a lot
in that podcast something we've touched
on this show is
how i got bobby lee to go see a
dermatologist because he had this big
gnarly oh thanks dan here
see no i don't even look close to his
fat i mean i look fat because i tried to
find the least flattering angle but
you're right it's not even close
so whatever that idiot had
did to me
donut okay
here i'll even try to make myself look
all nar as gnarly as possible
not as bad
it's pretty bad
so anyway um
yeah so i got bobby to go see a
dermatologist to get this crazy ass mole
removed and he was super pissed at me
for wasting his time but here bobby so
now check it out defending ethan so
after watching the wall situation with
bobby and ethan i decided to finally get
a mole removed from my back
that i always thought looked weird
because it was really dark
never really thought about too much of
it honestly after watching i decided to
get it removed and tested turns out it's
melanoma
and stage zero so caught it super early
just a friendly reminder for all the
foot soldiers please have your moles
looked at
for any irregularities thank you ethan
for getting me to the doctor you are
more than welcome
you're a hero send that to bobby
somebody so he can [ __ ] see that
you know i am the good guy anyway that's
that is awesome uh i'm glad that you did
that everybody check your moles
um
you know going off last week we had some
really bangers by the way we had the
bff's podcast which i think everybody
loved tiana mike
jeff
jeff won over the hearts and minds of me
or not my people loved tana and jeff
don't get me wrong but mike went over
the hearts and minds didn't that right i
think he he had the biggest swing
in uh audience perception it's kind of
funny because everybody's like just
assumes that he's just like a big old
dumbass
idiot because he's
i mean i like obviously i'm
we're good with mike now
i'm besties with mike we're dogs he's
the homie man yeah
but he is like a professional dick rider
for logan
um that's his job well that is his job
but we love him they've had their uh
trials and tribulations have they not
though wasn't there like
am i misremembering was there a little
window of time where
the the bromance had broken up actually
yeah mike was telling me about that he
it was like
i think mike said something about him on
a different podcast that was interpreted
to be yeah it was it was about the dress
about harry styles you come from maybe
sorry i couldn't resist
yeah it was about harry styles wearing a
dress and uh mike made a comment like
logan was just pandering to the audience
and it caused a little beef
and logan got super pissed and that's
what i'm saying he failed as a dick
writer he failed in that moment he made
his right his boy look bad right but i
love that i mean
nothing good nothing like your homie
riding your dick you know there ain't
nothing like your homie ryan love that
uh welcome maybe you're special thank
you
glad to be here i've got a beef to pick
with you today actually who the [ __ ] i
heard
yeah but anyway here's the original vote
jeff was you know own commanding lead
with 50 of all the votes tana
and second and mike wasn't even on the
chart i mean he was just decimated even
banks got seven percent right
and then by the end look at that or wait
no this is middle that was middle by the
end of it
oh jeff still won he did win it mike was
in the lead at the very last minute jeff
surpassed him okay but it was neck and
neck okay well shout out jeff yeah i
didn't want jeff to lose that status i
just he's he's been through enough yeah
you know
so
uh
anyway it was really fun glad you guys
enjoyed that it was nice to
squash some beefs there's more beefs i
want to squash too
there's more beefs i want to start today
so
it works itself out
my beef counter
man the barricades
uh also did you guys enjoy the interview
with uh
blake limon
the google engineer
who said uh
that
google created a sentient machine
i'm sorry dave
i'm afraid i can't do that
i liked it the thing is with that
i was just that whole
story was so captivating and the fact we
were able to get him on and talk to him
i thought was very cool
definitely i really enjoyed it yeah i
don't know if i was moved
completely i'm still
skeptical
but that's fully with the knowledge i
don't have the technical know-how to
really understand how these things work
but
i did think that his
wider point about uh what sentience is
not really being something that's
clearly defined um
took the uh the wind out of my hater
sales quite a bit well you know what
that was a very good point i i went into
that like very skeptical
and i came out of it a lot less
skeptical
because at the end of the day it's like
is something software is it sentient i
mean it really just becomes a
philosophical question right and and and
if something can imitate sentience close
enough
to make you even ask that question i
mean
it's it's functionally kind of hard
functionally what's the difference
it's kind of hard to distinguish you
know yeah
i thought it was real cool though glad
you guys like that one too um
let's see
you well amy since you're here i i guess
i'll just i gotta confront you on this
okay okay
there was this post on the subreddit
um
sure you saw it you probably upvoted it
500 times on your alts
no i don't like when people do that
stuff but i do appreciate it but
i feel like it puts me in an awkward
situation
it says avs jokes are so [ __ ] good
and they never fail
to just fly by ethan's head every single
time
i can't remember the last time ethan got
a joke for maybe without explaining
maybe the goat
of quick
and clever jokes
true
so
i just want to say okay
now are they saying i don't get his
jokes or
like it's too high level for me
well to be fair you have to have a very
high iq to understand uh abs humor right
so a b h kind of like rick and morty
abab humor
yeah i wanna first of all a b is very
funny i agree but the reason i don't
[ __ ] hear his jokes is because he
sits like 20 feet away from me and he
whispers it every goddamn time into the
microphone so you guys can hear it
perfectly and i can't hear [ __ ] i'm
literally like 20 feet away
so like i mean really it's abe's fault
you're saying it's a problem he whispers
it into the mic you got to project a
little bit
okay i was going to defend you now i'm
thinking it was changing it up
i was going to say speaking of my
position to hear me because you have
you're just hearing us mailing through
the speaker because yeah we're just
talking normal into our mics also you
got these lights on you there's a lot of
stuff going on
but yeah i don't take it personally i
know it's hard for you to hear take it
personally i can't hear you
how are you gonna take that person
you're whispering into a microphone
i don't know but that does beg the
question
if we need headphones or something
because a lot goes on there and i ask
what
a lot which is kind of annoying somebody
always be able to hear me it's a little
killer you project it's a little curious
baby never talks into his microphone
directly i'm just going to say that well
you know what
i just want to know can we find a way to
blame abs
yeah i don't know maybe some of the
stuff is just for the audience little
little gags just the audience yeah but
then everyone goes ethan's a [ __ ]
idiot and his well i'm sorry about that
[Laughter]
he whispers into the mic yeah he's
trying to tell you guys a little joke
does my mic sound bad right now sounds
fine sounds perfectly acceptable yeah a
little grainy if i'm being honest but
maybe what we can do i'm trying to think
of solutions but i'm not taking away
from you you are very funny so i'll
agree with them on that i would love to
hear your jokes i would i want to hear
your jokes too abe
i think maybe just like every time you
see me move in my mouth if you could
just give like a fake laugh or something
just pretend that i heard it just
pretend yeah
one of those
maybe what we could do is have a big oil
sign right and then somebody can
translate it and put it i can have a
button along with like my technical
difficulties button i can press please
laugh giant police clap yeah exactly
just abe said a joke button
please clap
dude people say is ethan just 40. i have
good hearing you guys there's there's
literally how much how many feet is this
let's find out yeah tan's going to
measure it okay
amy goes like this he's like
yeah so anyway that's pretty dumb and
you're like ooh
[Music]
i think i'm realizing that maybe i i
shout do i shout no you're great you
project like a queen dude fantastic also
i talk fast that may that may contribute
to uh to not hearing it well
no no you don't there's active lasers
okay i'm watching oh you're doing a
laser right into the laser
face forward okay all right
yeah that's dope a [ __ ] laser
measurement
also not 40 dude
37.
it is 15.47 i mean come on
dan how far am i dan how far am i over
here because i feel like i'm often
forgotten about too but i understand
that
i mean cam is like off basically i know
i'm like
probably 30 40. you have speakers over
there kim
speakers so you can hear us are you guys
viewers headphones we just fixed my
headphones so i can hear it in live time
before there was like a little uh delay
what's what's that what's the
measurement dan 34.92
just a pair shy of 35 feet that's a long
distance boy yep that's why yeah so i
don't know i guess that's why most pod
uh most shows wear headphones but
i personally think it's refreshing and
nice that we don't wear headphones
you know we're present
in the world
oh we all wear headphones but anyway
maybe you don't have to change i'm just
saying
uh i will do a better job at projecting
no i need to i agree you which i've
always had a problem you whisper those
sweet beautiful jokes into the mic
baby's like this he goes
anyway that's what she said
but if i say louder do i have to explain
every single one
yes you don't have to explain it if i
hear you ab you seem to be implying that
the problem is that ethan doesn't get
your yeah do you think that i don't is
that the problem
i think it's half half
you really think that your humor is too
high level for me is that what i'm
hearing i'm not high level i don't know
maybe it's on my end maybe i'm just not
funny but sometimes i do have to explain
there's a threat oh my god
[Laughter]
it's not funny
amy there's a thread here with 2 400
votes people telling you you're funny so
you're gonna sit here and be like i'm
not funny that's why you don't
understand it you're humoring me
that's legit not funny like you said
nothing like the homie's dick right
you're not dick riding you're dick
biting it's [ __ ]
using too much teeth
all right get the [ __ ] out of here go on
vacation are you on vacation or
something
i'm trying i'm trying i can't believe
i've only been here for a couple days
the amount of drama
going on here is crazy everyone's an
andrew tate fan it's [ __ ] wild oh my
god wait there's tate it's tater tot
city over there i was literally yeah in
a room in the basement full of friends
yesterday everyone's a tater tot oh my
shut the f wait can we talk to them at
some point yeah i want to probe a little
bit
i want to meet your buddies can i ask
you a question if you never met us
and you were friends with the same
people is there a chance you would be a
tater tot
no and that's what's so wild to me
because like my our families like
especially like my cousins i've always
been involved in like politics like my
dad and my uncles it's always been like
extreme left-wing but you know they've
been always left-leaning so
it's wild to me that i feel like since
kovitz started more of my hometown has
started to go right
so there your your boys over there are
jordan peterson and andrew tate that's
scary yeah
do you try to engage them on that
yeah i i feel like i'm equipped to a
degree after hearing you and dan mainly
all the time uh
like yesterday they were like oh this is
you know they're talking about what's
like andrew tate could actually fight
and they were debating and showing like
different like clips of his good fights
i go you know it's my favorite one
ironically and i showed him the one of
the video of him
[ __ ] up that girl like yeah that's
that's your idol right there oh and like
are you sure that's him i'm like yeah
dude that's that's
yeah it's not a question yeah oh that's
him he actually he he says it's him
so what do they think about that
they well they're like after he's seen
that i have to rethink some stuff yeah
okay
oh interesting you got through a little
they're receptive
[Laughter]
all right
well hold up i stay strong out there
thank you my the very funny uh a gifted
incredibly high level
a b ladies
[Music]
cracking us up every day
he does thank you guys thank you guys i
was trying to
stir [ __ ] up there a little bit but a b
is very funny he he he gets me real good
at least once an episode with one of his
comments that you don't hear i said that
thank you dan i'm sure he's funny always
understanding my jokes too funny dude
that's so lame bro that you're even
going there
[Laughter]
i'm gonna every time i hear ab whisper a
joke and i don't hear i'm gonna start
whispering back to everybody
that's funny
i'll be like
that's really cool
and then you also ask me what and i'll
be like you don't understand anything i
say bro
i'll start projecting
a b a b humor
all right thank you you're very funny we
love you
thank you
actually no offense to a b uh but can
you
move them off my tv
it's just it's all i can see
yeah all right i'm gonna go now okay bye
have fun see ya
see you next week see ya
the very funny ab ladies and gentlemen
the world famous
uh
the laugh factory known as
he's a one-man show
so um by the way i don't know why but i
can't see like
subscribers and super chats
on my chat log do you guys see it i do
you don't see it at home um you can see
the hundred dollar canadian donation oh
maybe that was the one you shot out
earlier no i don't see anything beat
yourselves yeah kings queens giving back
the podcast help me through oh yeah
somebody donated 50 and said please give
this to olivia
gorgeous awesome and we love her oh my
gosh wait okay good thank you somebody
got to keep track of that
[Applause]
um i think it has to do with adblock or
something is that possible because i saw
it when i refreshed and then it went
away
uh i've been updated there on that
laptop
since our last show so now i see it okay
now it's here okay
shout out kings
uh eric 50 for gorgeous olivia
thank you
thank you
so moving on um
this is kind of interesting
belle del fin
we've talked about her a lot years ago
on the show
yeah it's been a minute
but she was a pretty hot topic for a
minute eh
daddy um
well
she's got a new product on her website
that was seek i guess it was secretly
added
or quietly added i'll say
a hundred thousand dollars
for one night
what do you think zack
[Music]
[Laughter]
worth it or no
ah
i'm in a happy relationship right i
don't know what you're talking about
having said that
um
i do have a lot of fupacoin
oh maybe i can gift my fupa coin to
someone you want to see if there's an
equivalent exchange rate yeah
you know i thought
she says that you can have conversations
or deep throat face it
oral give or receive
prostate massage
[ __ ]
receiving wait domination mild and then
domination severe yeah those are two
different menu items
huh but i mean the price is the same
regardless right yeah it's just a
hundred thousand
i just got a day with her
and you can do it you can have the whole
the whole thing huh
i guess my question is she says uh spend
one night with me
you can keep it anonymous or you can
film the whole thing
and do whatever you want with it
i'm curious do you think anyone's to buy
that i mean she's kind of in my opinion
she's kind of baiting like rich
youtubers
i'm curious what 100 000 is a lot of
money though what love thinks about this
love would you partake
i mean i was curious if she would be
down to just play some games or
something for 100k
damn bro fortnite
yeah yo let's play fortnite
i feel like the opportunity to film it
is that adds like a lot of value that's
what i'm saying like it's like a sex
tape at that point right right you could
that person could like release it or
something you would make money well she
has sex on film now so it's not like
that
but if you're like somebody
yeah it's like a huge fan has sex with
yeah
biggest
crush or whatever i feel like
so i don't know i thought it was pretty
interesting
um
also just water sports is that like does
that mean wait what squirting or does
that mean like jet skiing
i think both okay she's up for she down
for whatever jet ski like right after
yeah so it's all on the menu
if anyone's out there looking no i
thought this would be for sure like i
thought some people were gonna buy this
but then i went to her gamer p
because she's selling her p for ten
thousand dollars
that's gross
how dare you judge her
i mean it's gross i
don't
feel bad saying that why are you hating
sex workers dan
i just feel like that's a bio hazard i'm
just kidding yeah it's just stirring
it's [ __ ] maybe i'm gonna pee in my
trash can down here i don't know i don't
know why it won't open because just take
the screen off for a minute ian thank
you
i'm just trying to get to the page
gamer girl p
what's going on here it won't load
it's too much traffic think so
oh you might be right with us watching
it live oh well there is that i think we
crashed your site okay you can show it
now
yeah but then i go well this gamer girl
p
has been on her website it's one of one
gnarlier the better
it's ten thousand dollars
and nobody's bought it
jesus is that a clear jar
yeah that's clear that's just some nice
homemade urine
damn
it's so foul
i mean if somebody wants to pay ten
thousand dollars for it i i have added i
suppose it's like kombucha at this point
right with all the cultures yeah yummy
probably has some health benefits that's
for real though
i mean there are people that drink
fermented urine like they're they love
that [ __ ] oh my god i sent you that that
yoga guy that's like all about pee
drinking did you watch that
yoga guy i don't remember no oh my god
let me see but there's like there's a
whole like tick tock slash yeah he's
like a tick tocker and he's like a a
yoga dude and he's all
he's all about the pee
it's just such an odd thing they go they
think that by drinking the urine they're
retaining the nutrients
and
um
but then there's even people who take it
even further and they'll pee in a jar
and let it sit for like a month to age
it and ferment it and then they drink
and i mean this [ __ ] is like next level
foul can we get doctor it's to confirm
that
you want me to text him
i'm down the stairs that's it you retain
nutrients from drinking your own urine
is it sugar-free
yeah keto
is a keto well that's a good question
well let's ask dr eds
yeah um people say yeah but they say
urine is
is uh they say it's a
sanitary or what is it one that doesn't
have germs people always say daryl they
always say that
i think yeah i also believe that that's
not true well let's find out is urine
sterile
i think it's debunked because despite
the rumor the bad things it says despite
the rumor urine is not sterile
it has bacteria
in it
well god damn it
i've been drinking my old urine all this
time somebody lied to me
i've been drinking the year and
but you know if you're trying to retain
your vitamins just go just eat a healthy
meal bro just have a salad
i've been chugging the water
[Laughter]
anyway are you guys think that anyone's
gonna buy this uh
this one night with bella delphine thing
i'm kind of curious
maybe
but like it's like
i i don't know
the uh pricing structure that is typical
for like high-end escorts and stuff like
that but 100 000 seems like a lot
yeah no no i don't think
i don't think high-end escorts cost
anywhere near that yeah actually they
can it probably cost maybe for a
high-end s god i don't know maybe like
10 000 for a really high-end one for
like the night see that that
sounds more in the ballpark to me but uh
i don't know anybody in the audience
that has a firsthand experience with
high-end escorts either zach either
being one or
just kidding let us know
yeah um well that's real interesting i'm
curious to see if anything comes out of
that i just wonder i was like man she's
maybe some youtubers are going to do
this but i says what's the crossover
between
youtubers
who are big enough to be able to afford
a hundred thousand dollars on something
like this
and who aren't
worried about posting a sex tape with
her
there can't be it can't be that big of a
pool can it maybe there is
somebody said
20 to 50k for a high-end uh escort so
it's not that far off i guess
thank you to
em uh emo jalapeno
for five gifted subs thank you thank you
thank you people keep saying love audio
i don't know yeah it's
we're aware
yeah but anyway that's pretty
interesting what is monaro by the way is
that like the new like silk road uh
crypto
monero yeah uh
i just looked it up it's
just another crypto coin uh i don't i
don't know what makes it special right
now
[ __ ] it's more than
167 dollars though so it's like one of
the time
time to invest
well there you have it
maybe we can pull our money for you zach
or something
um i'm okay i'm in a relationship
appreciate it though but i'm sorry i'm
very you passed the test yes
monero is untraceable basically black
market currency said somebody in the
chat okay well great
that's interesting that seems
uh
a little shady
yeah that's like the human trafficking
crypto the exclusive crypto of human
trafficking
mr beast would do it yo he would someone
said mr beast would do it and just make
her do a challenge i had sex with belle
duffy
i nutted inside belle delphine
i paid a hundred thousand dollars
so thick
there you have it
someone said send gabe
okay now that would be fun oh my god oh
my god is that a hundred thousand dollar
oh man gabe was that 100 thousand dollar
idea
i do like i do like buying a pointlessly
extravagant thing
i think you would make his life
as evidence of dan sitting in the
scoreboard you were saying you are
literally promoting a scam right now
somebody says in the chat how do you
know it's a scam
i don't know it's just you think she's
gonna run off with a hundred thousand
dollars and it is a little weird that
it's this untraceable currency that it's
uh but imagine gabe's smile when we tell
him
you think it's a scam i don't know i
don't think so she's she actually sells
this [ __ ] like the bathwater and all
that so
i mean where did you come across this
website
one you guys sent it to me oh i didn't
who found it
ian found it i think
i said on twitter 100 of scam not her
website wait that wasn't her website i
mean wait i just what people are saying
in the chat
seriously
well that's a [ __ ] crazy ass scam
then
i mean nobody's i mean they're not
nobody's sending a hundred thousand like
that
but
because her website looks just like this
belledelphine.club wait let's see if we
can blob
well hold on
oh my god
in reality
wait guys anyone who's sending a hundred
thousand wait
stop [ __ ] oh no stop
don't send it yet
can you guys confirm if it's her website
because i can't actually find her
official website when i type her name
well anyway kind of interesting so there
you have it
yeah maybe i'll send gabe
sell a sex tape with gabe and belle how
much do you think i could sell that for
oh somebody said bro i lost 100k sorry
no no no no no
yo caleb no
[ __ ] [ __ ] there was like 10
people that already sent 100k
wait can you guys try to find out if
that's a real website though i'm
actually curious
so yeah that was good
um pretty interesting
like by the way shout out to
kathleen
who is a beauty guru
by the way i love that we call like
beauty uh
people gurus
she's ascended
yeah but look look at this is so dope
kathleenlight shout out to the best one
is
peace and love shout out to the h3
podcast i literally named this eyeshadow
peace and love because not only is it
like a 70s saying
but this is a serious message oh my gosh
if none of you guys listen to ethan and
ela like or watch the h3 podcast you
have no idea what i'm talking about but
peace and love
peace and love we love you yes i love it
katherine light
and may i say
may i say that palette looks exquisite
boy look how vibrant those colors are
beautiful oh my god and the glitter
toppers insane forget it are you do you
know her by the way olivia yeah i've
been watching her since like oh
beginning of high school how nice
yeah this is awesome peace and love this
is a serious message the kathleen light
i want to tell you please
more palette names thank you thank you
yeah
uh so
getting into some juicy beef now trying
to trying to ease you guys into it uh
we're actually at 44 minutes already
maybe we should do our other ad and then
all right beef it up
so we have one ad stamps.com let's thank
them and then we'll get into all the
juice eh
thank you to
stamps.com yes we love stamps.com
yes are you having to drop what you're
doing to make a run to the post office
it's a major pain especially when you
have more important things to do
so stop mailing and shipping the hard
way
stamps.com your 24 7 post office that
you can access from anywhere skip the
headache with stamps.com stance.com
saves you time and money and stress for
more than 20 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over one million
businesses
uh dan's lovely girlfriend ali
uses it
she does for her business loves it yeah
he loves it it's great it's easy
no trips to the post office just print
the postage right there being bamboo
yeah
it's honestly this insane service
because they give you a scale
you weigh it on the website
they print out the postage you put it on
there and then here's the craziest part
they'll come pick it up or you can put
it in your post office like
this is the future my friends not only
that you get discounts
30 off ups usps rates and 86 off ups
let's go
that's the power
of stamps.com
whether you're sending invoices etsy
shops
products or warehouse a big old
warehouse shipping out
stuff
mailing and shipping is a breeze all you
need is your regular computer and
printer no special supplies or equipment
plus stamps.com seamlessly works shopify
amazon etsy ebay and more you're up and
running in minutes print the official
posters for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send it and you can
send
you can even
order shipping supplies through
stamps.com too
including free priority mail envelopes
nice
guys don't mail and ship the hard way
sign up at stamps.com today
sign up at stamps.com
h3tv
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale there is no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com
h3 tv
thank you thank you with peace and love
this is a serious message
[Music]
[Music]
okay
okay take me places zack
[Music]
let's keep it going why not
okay
[Music]
okay
where are we going
wow all right
thank you
what about
all right so first of all
you know this dude there's crazy trailer
updates apparently cav cav
like screwed over a bunch of black
creators
uh
we are working on interviewing them for
wednesday so that'll be fun
but one of my my other guy
uh keemstar shut up [ __ ]
that's what he's that's what the play
the sound bites so they know keemstar
shut up yeah shut up [ __ ]
dude how do you not leave the internet
after that
i think
after you get
bitched out like that publicly what was
that dude's name the greek billionaire
okay david yeah is she carrick you know
about that guy cam i know yeah he's a
piece of [ __ ] too yeah yeah but doesn't
surprise me yeah i mean
doggy dog but he top dog the other piece
of [ __ ] so
yeah so apparently so this this is kind
of crazy keemstar
is on snapchat trying to destroy my life
basically
he's not posting it on youtube because i
think
i think he thinks that he'll get in
trouble if he talks about me
what's funny is i don't care if he does
like i don't snitch i don't tell youtube
i don't do anything
but if he goes on snapchat
he can say whatever he wants about me
what's interesting about this
is that i was contacted
uh by somebody and told
that there was a lot of reports coming
through
about our show talking about keemstar
and that we had to tread lightly hmm
what what happened so yeah i know this
isn't that crazy and weird
somebody's being reported directly to
youtube
yes
like not just like flagging the video
the normal no no no no
like using contacts within the company
yes to
report people trying to get our channel
in trouble yeah interesting i know i
thought
[Music]
what they said
a lot of criticism yeah past about you
uh indeed
yeah so i think his master plan is
basically that
he's trying to bait me into responding
so that he can try to get me like the
second community strike because we have
one currently
for saying be the
the word don't need to reiterate yeah
don't don't actually need to
well i just want to remind the people
when they said i said b word
where everyone comes together and talks
about their cool toys
were you saying something cam when does
that first strike expire it's coming up
boy it's coming right around don't you
worry right around the corner let's go
we should get a countdown going
yeah
that's like a challenge to all of the
haters out there true yeah never mind
yeah so keemstar thinks he's like clever
i can't tell you guys how pathetic this
man is um
so he's on snapchat trying to bait me
into talking about him
so that he can report me to youtube
again for bullying him
and this is a 40 year old man who's
reporting people to youtube for bowling
and somehow i'm a snitch
come on
but listen to the kind of [ __ ] he says
about me he's accusing teddy fresh of
horrible [ __ ] right on snapchat
um
here it is and obviously i have to
respond to this
and i was just like i told listen i talk
to people i have a person here as a
person it's normal for big creators
at a certain point though he's gonna
have to lose that connect i mean his
channel i mean he's not even active on
youtube anymore
he hasn't even uploaded in three weeks
he goes if i can't talk [ __ ] about ethan
then i'm not posting anymore
i'll show him well he posted he left a
barbecue in a hurry to go to report on
uh
someone and following someone right i
think it was
charlie demilio unfollowing little huddy
or something
he dropped everything that's big news
though he got roasted so good on twitter
it was like had like 200 000 likes we're
like dude you're 40 years old it's
awesome
yeah but anyway i told youtube i was
like listen
if keemstar is saying this [ __ ] about me
even if it's not on youtube like i have
to
respond because he's saying teddy fresh
basically plagiarizes everything and is
stealing designs and all this [ __ ] right
and like this is a thing that him and
his
henchmen
keep trying to put out in the world
they're posting it to subreddits and
trying to make twitter threads and
trying to bait other commentary channels
and make videos about it so this is like
a whole big project of his
um it's crazy people don't realize what
this guy's actually up to i'm not
kidding this is all real by the way this
is the tweet i was talking about
this guy he ran home from a barbecue to
tweet this charlie demilio just
unfollowed little huddy it's going down
and brandon said a 40 year old man
tweeted this
hashtag dramaalert
the problem with dramaalert it was a
good idea at first but you do age out of
it i mean
at 40
you know you kind of age out of it
it's not an evergreen idea i feel very
foolish
sure yeah i get that anyway here's what
he posted on snapchat roll it
the h3h3 podcast co-host gila and ethan
klein are under fire now this podcast
criticizes other people in the community
and these two
recently have been criticized against
their clothing just the production of
this is insane
[Music]
crazy ass like inception music also goes
they're under fire watch he literally
pulls a tweet from some account with
like 300 likes that he probably
influenced to or just outright like paid
them
to post that [ __ ]
because
you know that's what he does
he's literally
he'll have someone else do it and then
report on it so he has no accountability
he does that all the time this guy is so
slimy
anyway here it is without further ado
building brand teddy fresh for allegedly
stealing designs let's read the thread
honey fresh a clothing brand by what's
what's going on with the setup what did
you say
oh what's what's with this roll back a
little bit why is he in a bar
he's in a bar
he's got
he's got by the way let me just say that
before we proceed no comments on his
intrinsic characteristics yeah that's
fine okay that's the rule i'm just uh
he's at a bar
he's got a broadcast mic and headphones
on but he seems to be recording on a
cell phone
is that right oh my god you're right
that doesn't make any squad wait is he
is he just set that up so it looks
official
i don't i don't know what the goal is
and why in a bar man
you're making content for kids and
you're in a bar what is this meant to
make you look cool that there's alcohol
behind you i mean it's his basement bar
right yeah yeah we saw it in his house i
recommend that place the the keemstar
fousey movie
rip to the goat by the way that got
taken down
so sad
the keemstar fousey feature film oh yeah
it's been a whole episode
was a masterpiece
anyway here he goes so i'm pretty sure
you're right he has a unplugged mic and
headphone and he's just holding the
phone isn't that
interesting super cool
on the community and these two oh my god
you're right have been criticized
against their clothing brand teddy fresh
for allegedly stealing designs
he's trying so hard do you guys see how
he's trying so hard to make this a thing
and he only posted it to snapchat
do you see that the the audio is
slightly delayed or it look almost looks
dubbed is that right from my point of
view yeah so i actually think he
recorded it on the mic
and then tried to overlap it and then
overlap it with his cell phone footage
maybe yeah but he didn't he didn't do it
perfectly i think you know it doesn't
look dubbed to me let me let me watch
oh it is there's a little i see that a
little bit yeah but that would be too
hard right to do that that'd be kind of
crazy because the audio is pretty good
so i think he actually so you think the
mic the mic might be he might have done
got the audio track and merged it with
the video okay but i think he [ __ ] up
a little bit yeah it's a little off
you're right you're right man it's a
little delayed
wow
who would have thought that this
production from his basement bar
wouldn't have been perfect
so frustrating i know buddy
just next time be a little more careful
with the sink there's tools that can
help you with that adobe who recently
have been criticized against their
clothing brand teddy fresh for allegedly
stealing designs let's read the thread
teddy fresh a clothing yeah again this
was some post by uh
i don't know it had like almost no likes
it was like the only person that saw it
was keemstar
okay [ __ ]
he's like friends they're there you
gotta get 14 likes
he's like they're under fire from this
account with 14 likes
really dude
and you're making a whole video about it
okay let's watch
and by ethan and gila cline might have
been stealing designs for years
a teddy fresh shirt bottom an original
vintage shirt a bear the exact copy and
paste and if you look close that is the
same bear are they just taking this but
the thread keeps going people that's
right capela's dangerous hunt peter ps3
video game on top
teddy fresh t-shirt on the bike the same
bear what is this
what's going are they really just taking
designs are they stealing them and the
threat keeps going people now i i know
this story this happened a couple months
ago because h3's own fans were exposing
him for stealing a dino shirt a sweater
pattern from 1992 first of all okay well
i'm just gonna let it finish then i'll
go back and address everything dino
design from a sewing book on the top and
on the bottom a teddy fresh sweater and
apparently ethan klein even admitted
that this was stolen by you know an
employee that they fired but the thread
keeps going people top vintage teddy
bear design found on etsy bottom teddy
fred
that's like the same thing i'm noticing
a pattern here people and speaking about
patterns continuing on the thread look
at this look at this
it's the same
thing
it's the same thing the blue flames it's
the same thing top vintage design found
on epsy bottom teddy fresh not real is
teddy fresh just like stupid designs
from everyone now recently teddy fresh
came out with this elon musk with devil
horns type of thing
it's like black and white and then only
the red is shown right
well that is another t-shirt design
stolen from like ins what what is this
yeah i mean it seems like somebody is
trying to hide this information from
getting out but ladies and gentlemen
again no i'm literally showing it for
everybody because i know what you're
trying to do you're trying to create a
story nobody's hiding it this isn't even
a story you created out of thin air
under the guise of some other dude that
you had tweeted out
and uh
i'm not hiding [ __ ] bro you idiot
i want to know what you think hit me up
on twitter with your thoughts my twitter
is at keemstar and that is it for the
news make sure you subscribe here
because you know as soon as i get the
scoop that's it for the news
yeah all the news that happened that day
i've never heard of that website epsy
ebc yeah they make epstein's salt they
sell salt i think what is pepsi
pepsi oopsie
you know
you could tell how hard he's driving and
i feel like he put a lot of work into
this you know
he put a lot of work into this and he's
four years he's trying so hard and the
thing about teddy fresh
i think he's so bitter and jealous about
teddy fresh because it's successful in
its own right and there's really nothing
shady going on with teddy fresh and he's
so desperate to hurt me in any way he
can he tried lying about me he's tried
ruining my youtube channel
uh and that that hasn't worked uh so
he's now going after my wife and her
company
and like he didn't post this on youtube
just snapchat don't you find that
interesting
because he knows he can't be reporting
he can't be complaining to youtube that
i'm bullying him and then posting [ __ ]
like this so he posted on snapchat
but of course i'm going to defend myself
against accusations like this it's not
bullying if you [ __ ]
if you provoked me
but let's say let's go back okay to and
let's take these on
uh head on
i mean this is my wife's company we're
talking about here
and by the way for my wife i mean to
give me a break bro
i mean i would never go after your
girlfriend
knock it over my wife there it is i mean
she's only i mean i would never go after
a child
you know she should i wouldn't do that
yeah no you shouldn't it's too far
anyway let's take by the way i want to
say at the top okay
i mean at this point teddy fresh has
been in business for five years and each
collection each month we drop a lot of
coll of clothes i mean we have a lot of
designers we have like
again there's like
about 40 people there
full-time employees
and we've probably made like close to a
thousand maybe a thousand products by
now damn okay
and if he only found like maybe eight
things that he could try to accuse us of
stealing
so like per capita or right off the bat
you're talking about
a company with 40 employees that's made
thousands of designs
so let's let's let's talk about this
let's read the thread teddy fresh a
clothing brand by ethan and gila klein
might have been stealing designs for
years
a teddy fresh shirt bottom an original
vintage shirt a bear the exact copy and
paste and if you look close that is the
same bear
are they just taking this but the thread
keeps going yeah so
that the one hilarious thing
that they're trying to get us on is like
sometimes designers just license
graphics
from a
because it's really hard to create
custom
graphics all the time and it's very
normal for clothing brands streetwear
brands to license an image
and start from that
and it's just it's incredible because
they're so desperate again
to try to [ __ ] with my life
that they're
it's like dude it's a licensed graphic
you [ __ ] idiot
like
it's just not that deep
um
it's really not
sometimes keemstar things aren't that
[ __ ] deep thank you bank wow bff [ __ ]
i told you he was bff material did he
steal this by the way i love that he
considers himself a journalist
did he steal this design
does he really
i mean
i think he does actually sadly i really
i think he does fancy himself
as some kind of journalist
which is kind of nuts
uh thank you dylan for 10 gifted subs
appreciate you thank you for the time
thank you for giving it
meat thank you for gifted didn't fight
gifted get me think thinking
uh
for your and sorry your name is so hard
to pronounce
uh but thanks for the 20 you said what
is the logo on keem's shirt looks ripped
off from nirvana oh [ __ ] girl that's an
interesting observation is it yo
that's his punch is his boxing promotion
thing
he stole that from nirvana dude
wait hold on type happy face with one x
i
hear it's
pull it up
now the nirvana one has two x's
here's a good side
he completely ripped that off
oh my god this is my
oh my god you guys this is crazy are
they just stealing it what the hell
this is nuts
we caught him red-handed i've been
seeing i've been seeing a lot of reports
about this in uh in our discord channel
breaking news breaking news trying to
hide this
uh is he stealing designs
breaking
the happy face is clearly the same
keemstar
we need an answer from you
by the way
breaking news
[Music]
shocking news
can you i bet you can find this i don't
think they made this i bet this is like
a licensed image the face
yeah yeah it's gotta be
breaking news keemstar is stealing it
he's stealing it
but i mean this is this is the level of
you know
journalism that's going into this like
it's so it's so absurd
and then there's this one
oh my god you guys this this is
unbelievable what i'm saying i mean this
is a direct ripoff i'm just i can't
believe the balls on this guy
like guys
what are we gonna do about it
is this covert related
ow
so anyway let's continue so there's that
one
let's read the thread teddy fresh a
clothing brand by ethan and gila klein
might have been stealing himself
four years the exact copy and paste and
if you look close that is the same bear
are they just taking this what the
threat keeps going people that's right
capela's this is a licensed image
but honestly it's so different too like
even making the accusation is kind of
insane
it may not even be a licensed image i
don't know it's hard to tell but like
it's a video game cover
and this is completely different the
bears from a completely different angle
it's hard to tell yeah you're right you
can see more of
you see it's more front-facing but
it doesn't it doesn't matter i mean i'm
pretty sure that this is a reference
this is a
i think this they're actually using a
licensed image
on the front of their video game but we
we actually changed it quite a bit
so it's even
even licensing aside it's quite a
stretch
again thousands thousand designs over
five years and this is the best he has
dangerous hunt peter
ps3 video game on top
teddy fresh t-shirt on the bite the same
bear
it's the same shirt
ladies and gentlemen it's the same shirt
as a ps3 bear
i can't believe it
we got him folks
shut it down
[Music]
kurt cobain will like a word with you
someone says uh megan said i hope you're
not stressing too much ethan we're
noticing your ticks are more
uh also sign up please talk about deaf
noodles i don't want to talk about that
first of all thank you
i'm okay
you know one of the causes from the more
tourettes could be the wellbutrin i
started
i don't know
but yeah it has been more lately which
is annoying but it's fine i can deal
with it um the other thing is
i don't talk about deaf noodles you know
the dude's been getting like
absolutely dog piled by everybody
i'm not i'm not gonna do that
so let's continue this
ever what is this
what is go are they really just taking
designs are they are they really just
turkey designs
stealing them are they stealing them
uh from
mermaid
sorry if i'm saying that wrong uh senior
graphic designer for a major apparel
company here this is all extremely
normal in the industry exactly much love
to you and tf thank you stay losing
thank you that's it
first of all thank you for that message
because it's hard to convey
like there is norms in the industry that
everybody knows and like when you're
outside like keemstar that's like
looking at everything we do
under a microscope
these things that are
quite literally uh you know
business norms this this is what happens
in every design room for every
every you know fashion company in the
world i've i've heard that supreme
they have a massive warehouse full of
vintage clothes
and when they're going to design they
basically just walk through and like
pick out vintage items and basically
just rip it off more or less and that's
kind of the
cycle of things it's it's it's what it
is
a lot of these companies too have such a
set
list of assets you can get
and they're very strict on how much you
can manipulate them too
so
i don't know oh you're saying the
license yeah the licensing yeah it's
interesting
yeah but there's i mean yeah it's it's
like
it's it's just nuts
people now i i know this story this
happened a couple months ago because h3
history's own fans were exposing him for
stealing a dino shirt a sweater i mean
this is such old news we're like bros
with this guy now
we have a partnership with him we pay
him and we're actually making more stuff
together hey nice yeah we have a really
cool
another sweater
coming out of his sweater designs it's
they're so dope it's a cat
and a dog wearing a turtleneck sweater
on a sweater so [ __ ] dope what
reception gary kennedy shout out
so yeah dude really uh breaking news
here buddy
you know again thousands of designs and
he's rehashing this old buried [ __ ]
that's been done forever the pattern
from 1990 oh wow
thank you to blue phoenix productions
lots of goofs going on right now but i
wanted to say how great you guys are
every podcast
makes my day thank you guys for the
endless laughs and thank you for
watching and i'm so happy to
be with you guys
four times a week
that's the dream one day five
one day
but until then yeah shout out gary
kennedy he's the one who made this
design to a dino design from a sewing
book on the top and on the bottom a
teddy fresh sweater and apparently ethan
klein even admitted that this was stolen
by you know an employee that they fired
but the threat keeps is he trying to be
like you know an employee trying to make
it seem like it was us he's like you
know an employee
whatever going people top vintage teddy
bear design found on etsy bottom teddy
fresh that's like this to be honest i
can't tell what's going on here if it's
the same or not
but i will say um about this one again i
can't tell if it's
it was the same
it's possible that it's a fabric
uh that we bought
but it's also possible
the thing is like
there is an industry standard for when
you buy really really old vintage stuff
that's like a one-off that like doesn't
exist anywhere it's years old
it's like
a public domain it is
there is like a weird thing but people
it's kind of like fair game i feel like
if you discover like a one-off weird
thing that's like forgotten to the
annals of history
um
you shouldn't copy it
uh directly though i mean that obviously
shouldn't do that i can't tell though
this one's too small i can't see the
i can't even tell if they're identical
or it may have been the same fabric or
it may have just been a vintage piece i
don't know
same thing i'm noticing a pattern here
people and speaking about patterns
if it was the same why didn't you get a
closer pick you could you know what i
mean
you could well it's for a snapchat show
so it's only ever gonna be uh but this
one's gonna get closer to the screen
yeah
okay
i'm noticing a pattern here people and
speaking about patterns continuing on
the thread look at this this is this
one's my favorite this is a [ __ ]
fabric you [ __ ] we bought the same
fabric you dumb disease-brained [ __ ]
idiot
i mean
seriously it's this is so sometimes
people manufacture
uh really cool fabrics
and you speak with certain you know you
have like fab textile vendors or people
you work with and you say
you know send us some really cool
fabrics you have right now
and they'll send samples and you go dang
that's awesome i want to use that
and so uh clearly
they like the same pattern uh the same
fabric as us
and that's all that happened
so shout the [ __ ] out keemstar
is getting education this one
i will admit is
too a little too close for comfort i
don't know what happened with this one
uh
to be honest
do we know where the sweater from the
left oh yeah it's prada i recognize that
sweater is a prada sweater
with the flames
i mean this one's on a hoodie
yeah i mean this this one's a little
sush i agree i'm not sure what happened
here
yeah that's maybe the only one that i
that he could call me out on that i can
probably look a little deeper into
look at this
it's the same thing it's the same thing
the blue flames it's the same thing top
vintage design
blue it's clearly green right that's not
blue i don't want to be
i just i don't want to be like a color
ableist but maybe um my mom is
colorblind
i think you might be colorblind keem
well you could be you could do a color
test anyway you know colors have changed
my life
color blindness is more common in men
yeah my mom mixes up green and blue and
brown and red interesting
yeah
ames it's the same thing top vintage
design found on epsy bottom teddy yeah
this is the this is what i was saying
this is like a super old vintage design
that's like erased from the annuals
anals of history
and i mean it's different the colors are
different and stuff too so i don't i
don't really see the problem in this
case it's just a t-shirt
fresh unreal is teddy fresh just like
stealing designs from everyone now
everyone
teddy fresh came out with this elon musk
with devil horns type of thing
it's like black and white and then only
the red is shown right
well that is another t-shirt so i made
this design i've i've never seen this in
my life and this is by far the biggest
stretch i just i don't even know because
like obviously this is like a trope
right with the red of course crayon and
the horns and [ __ ]
so i don't know anything about this
shirt i designed this shirt i've never
seen that one that first one is a black
and white photograph with drawing over
it right
and this one is a doodle
yeah but if you google
red horns and crayon
you'll find that the whole internet is
plagiarizing
each other it's crazy yeah it's [ __ ]
yeah so this is just obviously like a
major stretch here right
well that is another t-shirt design
stolen from like insta what what is this
yeah i mean it seems like somebody is
trying to hide this information from
getting out but ladies and gentlemen i
don't and that that the final
insinuation that we're somehow
someone bearing this uh extorting people
going to and so what he obviously he's
trying to turn this into a thing right
and this is what he does and the thing
is some of you guys don't like when i
talk about keemstar so much but i have
to address these things before they
snowball and that's what happened when
he accused me of stealing money for our
first lawsuit i just ignored ignored an
order i was trying not to talk about
keemstar at all and it actually almost
ruined my life which is kind of crazy so
he he actually goes so low
uh that when i almost he almost ruined
my life and i had to
really come back hard on him and that's
when people
left me alone on that issue and decided
that i wasn't a scammer and that's what
he's trying to do here
it's hard to explain just what a
existential threat this guy is to people
he hates
and that's why i talk about him so much
is because
he thrives on bullying people and like
destroying people's lives and
i'm his i he hates me more than anyone
so as you can see
he's trying to do it still and on top of
that it's like the metabate where he's
doing it on snapchat only debate me to
talk about him so he can report me to
youtube he's trying to get me banned on
youtube
it's crazy right i mean it's like this
man thinks about
he really thinks about me all the time
[Laughter]
yeah just uh as lin lydia said i just
hope david's okay
oh true
thank you lydia for bringing us back to
earth there
i'm just worried about david
olivia i said lydia oh lydia
but anyway you know um
so that's keemstar trying to ruin my
life on just another day another dollar
i want to know what you think hit me up
on twitter with your thoughts my twitter
is at keemstar and that is it for the
news yeah cam you have a good point cam
said he might just be embarrassed by his
youtube views i think you're right to a
degree but i also think he's trying to
bait me
dude this thumbnail goes so [ __ ] hard
cam
thank you
but we are going to war
yeah i mean he hasn't uploaded in four
weeks dude he can't get half a million
anymore yeah it's like so i mean i think
the last time he got a million was when
he uh clickbaited that he was retiring
yeah
poor kim yo look at the bottom left
he never fixed it
which one the hassan oh racist
yeah you're right we
we tipped you off bro it says rasist
you misspelled it
he must get like 10 000 views on his
snapchat show that's what i want is
there a way to see how many views
snapchat stuff gets i don't think it's
public oh that's a shame
well i agree i don't think a lot of
people saw it because this i didn't even
see this float to my consciousness i
think a b showed it to me but you know
what a b said which is kind of
disturbing it was on his home page so
maybe a lot of people are seeing it and
then didn't you also say it was on your
homepage cam
no not me but i think somebody else
wasn't one of you guys i did i did oh
you saw it on your home page
uh he's been on there for years
super long he must have like a decent
contract with him probably is my guess
because he's been on there for ages
so you open i've never used snapchat i'm
not a sexual offender so i don't have a
use for her
uh not i'm just saying because i'm old
and married and
you guys are allowed to use snapchat i
think you have to be young to use
snapchat
but uh so you open the thing and then on
the home page they curate content for
you like youtube homepage yeah there's
like a discover page with a bunch of
stuff on there yeah
interesting he just showed up there so
it's probably is getting a lot of views
then he's not on mine right now it's not
on mine seeing some people in the chat
report it was on theirs i saw it online
well there you go so you know there you
go
yeah i've seen quite a few people say
that that's good i have been caught in
4k so that's why i need to respond to
this [ __ ] you know so there you have it
uh here by the way he talked about me
well two months ago yeah he stopped
uploading oh ethan calls for oh yeah
this is my favorite headline ethan calls
for bombing u.s citizens
what was it
what was the thumbnail why did it say no
nut
ethan klein calls for bombing u.s
citizens based on political difference
man he was going in he thought this was
his chance
yeah what did it say no not something
it said so bad no nut
no not
this
so bad i'm so bad and logan is no nut
i love that pick of logan though dude
look at that picture of him screaming
like a maniac
no not so not so not i love nobody nails
i gotta say
it's just
consistently so [ __ ] funny
terrorist
yeah so that's what's going on with him
go to teddyfresh.com
and pick yourself up some original
wonderful designs
made by uh my wife and a bunch of
talented people
check it out guys keemstar if you're
watching you can get a discount use code
keemstar oh i should do that i should
run a promotion code keemstar
[ __ ] that'd be so epic
i should do that i'm literally gonna
take the teddy fresh away
wait
are you in tr are you are you um in
contact with sarah
well yeah she can set up a coupon code
for us oh my god
called keem use code kim this is not a
little corny no it's all according is it
i thought it'd be funny i just feel like
keep teddy fresh out of the drama sphere
you know
well it's not a public coupon it's just
for food troopers oh i see it's not like
on the website you won't be like it's
just for people watching well i can send
her a message no i wouldn't put that on
the home page [ __ ] hell no
it's just for a little inside joke
we can do it for like two days or
something yeah 30 off
use code keem
really 30 holy moly i know it's crazy
this is just brand new [ __ ]
let's go
and then i know it's crazy let's go 30
whole percent
[ __ ] hell thank you
actually insane
30. holy moly holy queen code get it
wow yeah tell ask sarah you're in charge
you're in contact with her yeah tell her
set up code keem
for two days or maybe maybe three days
so people get yeah
or maybe until yeah i don't know what do
you think two days
just me i don't know
know the financials of this
three days should we run this by ila ah
probably i choose down i know i should
probably spread it yeah
this is
she's gonna find it funny here let me
call her on the let me call her see what
she thinks
no [ __ ]
oh i got cute pictures of her and
theodore they're having a fun mommy
sunday today oh i'm jealous cute
oh my
come on now it was just it was just oh
no didn't say anything um
by the way we've had so much such a nice
time at home ela's family's in town and
they have three young kids
oh and their theodore's just getting on
so well with them
we've been having like pool parties and
he's just in heaven it's been awesome oh
ela's calling
hey i'm live i'm live
okay hey i know you're live i'm
listening i do not find it funny
and
uh thank you
[Laughter]
i had again feeling
so that's it that's a no on code
yeah i'm actually driving and i was just
gonna start looking for my phone to
message you guys on what's up
and then that was like maybe we should
ask
he's driving sales for us
yeah no it's funny but like
nah
nah
no you've heard it here
how was your day with teddy those
pictures look cute
that was great
yeah he's been in such a good mood it's
been so nice so i got him he picked a
lego set and he was like um
we got to show this to daddy he's gonna
freak out
it's so funny he's starting to get
really good with his words he's like
three yeah he's just over three but he's
starting to say the funniest stuff
all right well okay i'm glad that uh
i'm glad that you stopped me okay
someday someday
maybe when we do that maybe when we do
oh no i can't talk about that what
okay all right love you bye
thank you okay all right bye
make sure they behave
what about five percent people are
asking
all right well
no did that
oh it was worth it
that was a great moment no
all right i was getting their credit
cards out i know [ __ ]
all right
that was fun
uh moving on
we oh now it's time to talk about dave
pork boy
who has been trying to settle squash the
beef with really i have been trying
yeah you were even like being
somewhat complimentary to him just
recently you're saying yeah and funny
and you like pizza reviews and all that
yes exactly and so what i don't like
about david
david
like his mom
uh if i may call you that
is that one he's pretending like he
doesn't know who i am and i find that a
little corny because at first
i was like maybe he doesn't know who i
am and you guys sent me a clip
of him being like
talking about me that he knows me so i
don't know it's a little corny david
when you guys have had back and forth
yeah yeah multiple times so
but anyway here it is bfs
h3 podcast won a rant accusing dave and
bff specifically specifically of giving
them a copyright strike after they use a
clip from our podcast and youtube's
fingerprinting technology automatically
gave bffs a copyright claim
h3 accused bffs is striking their
youtube video when youtube auto
populates this on its own so we're
defending itself austin told me about
this
i know we've talked about this guy ethan
klein if you told me ethan oh okay so he
did okay never mind he's good kline's
name maybe it was an old video where he
said that and then last week i've been
like who's ethan klein oh no see
who's gonna say it's it's here okay well
he had no idea what austin's uh was
talking about and ethan klein has me
pegged
quite incorrectly if he thinks i'm
running around
moderning who's using our [ __ ] clips
let's watch what he said
[Music]
seriously you guys are making a joke
about us copyright claiming when you
guys [ __ ] strike up my video down
like bro how corny can you get unlike
you guys i don't claim or especially i
don't strike down
footage of ours dumbass
[Music]
i but just a lunacy to think that we are
issuing can play is it by the way isn't
it good when other podcasts use your
clips yeah that's what you would think
right dummy it's great user clips all
the time yeah and we don't want youtube
to like strike you or do anything that
we want our clips out there so that just
lunacy yeah so basically what happened
what's the copyright clip even do for us
like what so basically well at this
point i think i'll just
i mean what he calls lunacy is um
quite literally provably true
h3 podcast due to a copyright takedown
notice that we received we had to take
down your video
takedown issued by bar stool sports
this means that your video can no longer
be played on youtube you've received one
copyright strike
well that doesn't seem to mince any
words on that one does it david
i don't know who did it but somebody did
it
first of all and by the way
listen you gotta look at your [ __ ]
you gotta figure out how the copyright
system works because you're out there
doing first they claimed the podcast
we disputed it
mm-hmm
and then you and then they counter
disputed it and claimed it basically it
gets to the point where they're like you
can either
file a dmca and take down the video and
give them a strike or you can just let
it go and they chose in the face of our
disputes
to
give us a [ __ ] strike and remove the
video
there's no
there's no if ands or buts about it they
did it
and i was ready to forgive him too
because they let it go but now he's out
here talking mad [ __ ] dude
and i'm not down with it
especially doing that like oh we didn't
include it because they're gonna
copyright strike us like [ __ ] you're
the one copyright striking people man
the barricade let's just hope yeah i'm
hoping that this one doesn't get
copyright striked
dummy
i mean
i believe him when he says he doesn't
have anything to do with it too i said
that in the original one but i'm a
lunatic right he's saying i'm a lunatic
i'm crazy why would we ever do that and
well you guys need to get a hold of your
[ __ ] this is your show right you three
[ __ ] goons are running a show you
should know what the [ __ ] is going on
there
are you going on the show are you ready
i already do that and i don't want to
i'll tell you why because i don't know
they're all on zoom and then they wanted
me to come in and sit with like josh and
they're on zoom
you can i don't know it's just like i
don't know i like to meet dave in person
if we do it personally
i find it difficult to do good
interviews on zoom
also it's important to me that they can
get a really unflattering angle of me
which they won't be able to do on zoom
right i think yeah that's important to
us
it's content
one shot everyone knows the rules but
yeah if you don't have the context
you're like ethan's insane he's a
lunatic why would we do that we would
never do that oh and by the way he's
going to copyright strike us so figure
your [ __ ] out bro i have a show i know
what goes on here do you
do you know what the [ __ ] goes on on
your show dave no that's why your show
sucks because you're barely involved in
it idiot
maybe i'm taking it too far maybe well
yeah well i mean we said we were going
to war we're reverting back into old
taking it too far but this should piss
me off dude
i mean come on like just the girl by the
way was her name melissa or something i
don't wanna
it's just a first name but i'm saying it
wasn't that i'm just saying
that
it would be very easy for you to figure
out what happened here instead of
blasting me
on your show and calling me an idiot
right that's what i wondered like
because it's like it would be very if
you decided to talk about it on the show
wouldn't you like
call up whatever employee handles this
stuff to like see did we do we do
something with this they just assume it
was the automated no this is crazy this
is right this is lunacy i was out
getting a slice i don't know what's
going on and it might i mean maybe it
was an overzealous you know
employee of his
i don't give a [ __ ] i said in the
original one i doubt it i obviously
said it was him for the for the you know
the scoop but i said in the thing
i'm sure he didn't even know that about
this
anyway let's continue
what happened we get the money yeah so
what happened is they got sent to it
saying like this has bfs content so the
money would go to us
like we get that all the time on bfs and
we do nothing they said no we don't
agree with that youtube looked at it and
ruled and said well this is clearly the
content so the episode has to come down
if you want stupid [ __ ] liar
or just so incompetently ignorant
you're lying dude you youtube doesn't do
take down videos bro what a [ __ ]
weasley little oh my god dude
it's just they're such liars
it's just not how it works you have to
physically it's a legal notice you have
to [ __ ] type in your information and
literally sign it
literally lying like you're just such a
[ __ ] liar bro i hate when people
abuse the copyright system and then just
be like it was automated it's like [ __ ]
it wasn't it was not automated
it i probably even said manually claimed
but
i know for a fact that dmca's have to be
filled the [ __ ] out so
[ __ ] your mom you can apologize anytime
like this has bfs content so the money
would go to us
like we get that all the time on bfs and
we do nothing they said no we don't
agree with that youtube looked at it and
ruled and said well this is clearly that
kind of thing doesn't make judgments on
copyright bro you're how dumb are you
that's what our legal system is for
that's why i'm being [ __ ] sued for
fair use
so the episode has to come down if you
won't pay them the money
yeah youtube said to them they're not
paying you the money so we're taking the
video down makes no sense
and also the strike has been removed
anyway
like yeah we get all the times like we
do this all the time we don't want to
get [ __ ] with it on the other end
did they say they do this all the time
did they just admit that they do this
all the time
we don't care
yeah that's that's the bottom line like
yeah
we get all the time like we do this all
the time we don't want to get [ __ ]
with it on the other end well you know
we we do it all we get that thing all
the time most time we just let the other
if we want the clip that bad we just let
them keep the money on like the youtube
stuff oh they do claim people all the
time that's what he says right i do it
with him i don't blame anybody i don't
[ __ ] claim anybody i think he's
saying that they get copyright claimed
all the time no i don't think here
listen
and that
they let the other person collect the
money if they claim it okay let's let's
see and and we we we do it all we get
that thing all the time most time we
just let the other if we want the clip
that bad we just let them keep the money
on like oh okay well right if you don't
[ __ ] care about your
business that's that's your problem
you don't understand fair use that's
your problem not mine like the youtube
stuff
yeah you're right olivia though that's
what he meant yeah but yeah he's living
in his own fantasy land that we give a
[ __ ] about that um
okay well
once again
thank you shredder
shredder didn't like once again
i'll be accepting apologies from dave
oh the tv went out
oh
the dog oh shredder my boy
sabotaging
you know if people didn't want beef then
why the [ __ ] they start [ __ ] with me
i'm trying to be the new ethan the
knights ethan what's up get away from
that [ __ ] of me being fat cut it
i'm trying to be the new ethan why you
gotta come lie on me dave i'm trying to
be friends with you
saying i'm living in my fantasy world
you idiot
yeah maybe if you were partnered with 18
year olds someone wouldn't have their
head all the way up their [ __ ] ass
and they'd be able to
[ __ ] know what was going on back
there listen ethan i don't i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on in my company i
just i just eat pizza all day i just
drink high moon and i yell at the red
sox game i [ __ ] suck right now don't
oh dave you are so
dave you are
so right in everything you do dave you
are just like the coolest guy i've ever
met dad cam and i always do this back
and forth where we're dave and josh
oh dude
dave you are so absolutely 100 million
percent correct and everything you've
ever said in your entire life dad
you are just the coolest guy come on kid
everyone knows the rules one bite come
on just meet your friends come on one
strike come on everybody knows the rules
it's just one strike oh dave can we
pretend like you're tom brady and like
i'm your son
oh
kiss me on the lips yummy
like that i love that he's the best i'll
kiss you right now we're getting it can
we get it on the tick tock with the tick
tock thing with your friends on there
yeah your friends on there
wow i am blown away
cam has got a good port noise i'm very
shy yeah dude's living in a fantasy
world he's a [ __ ] psycho he's lying
josh they're talking [ __ ] about us again
just strike him down right now copyright
struggle
cam you love dave don't you oh uh well
hold on
yeah no there's you're not going to find
a boston sports fan that doesn't have
some appreciation no you just gotta but
he [ __ ] sucks [ __ ] him sulks and six
come on dude on the way to be friends
with the guy he says he's lying this
dude's lying he's in a fantasy world
[ __ ] liar dude
you're [ __ ] crazy you're crazy
copyright strike him again what is that
dave give him strike two show this one
more time okay
there you have it
okay
suck my tiny jewels you're asking for
another one right now
you give him more strikes in the socks
dude watch they're gonna give us another
one and then say i'm crazy again
there you have it shout out dave port
boy
ladies and gentlemen
thank you
dr ed is he still available we wanted to
ask him if drink his thoughts on
drinking urine
dr ed's the
health expert researcher nutritional
researcher md
doctorate
is on the line he's going to give us
some advice on drinking your own urine
is it good for you or not let's get the
facts we'll see the meta studies
i'm not taking a pause to pee
it's a reminder
healthier than water i know that's so
funny i saw
somebody posted that and he commented
ryan or harvey did oh yeah yeah shout
out yeah he posted it and the doctor is
on twitter was like i didn't say that
yeah here
yeah i did not say that
it's what we heard doctor it's what we
heard
i think his did say that you know
whether you said it or not it doesn't
matter it's what we heard
uh you guys are saying bestie alert
ethan and dave have more in common okay
i'll buy it what is it
it's just not for me
and that's okay
i can always get the button on my pants
let out
but i can't get those moments that i
[ __ ] hate working out that's what i
said
where's all the dave pork noy beta
compilations wow
like that's my [ __ ] joke that's my
material
interesting what i'm seeing is he stole
my jug
if i'm being honest it don't work out
this is my workout high noon up
high noon down high noon up
high noon down
that's my workout
[Music]
bro i agree
i just want somebody please make dave
portnoy beta compilations
i need the alpha males to get their
hands on this
see it's not that crazy what i said
oh
kim and trish what is this oh did you
know keemstar was on
bffs that's another reason not to go on
there i mean how desperate are they for
guests
keemstar was on there
well how long ago
that's the question
why doesn't it say publish date
well the to the recent comments it says
11 months so probably 11 months
is it supposed to be time stamped
oh yeah dude this is this just cracks me
up by the way
oh the title is trisha paytas for his
keemstar over his 20 year old girlfriend
love that
um there's one sound bite of course
whenever he goes on anybody's podcast
anytime
he gets the opportunity to speak to a
new audience what's the one thing he
does without fail
the one thing he does without fail
he talks about me baby not only does he
talk about me he talks about how my dick
doesn't work
like he's obsessed with sharing that
it's so great by the way my dick works i
just said it has less sensitivity
because i take
antidepressants
off yeah thank you but even if it didn't
i it's i don't care like it doesn't
bother me i just think it's kind of
embarrassing that he brings that up
every time
by the way if we're to talk about
bowling if he's going to report me every
time to youtube for making fun of his
intrinsic features this man's
making fun of my medical condition we
need to make a compilation of that
see who's bowling who next one is most
likely to backstab their friend
oh uh jayden hostler ethan klein
oh wow you say ethan klein or would not
trisha i just love that the bat even the
backstabbing thing is like dude you
don't even know me
no well i mean trisha you know after
there's uh you know a legitimate breakup
between her and another friend then she
starts dogging them and she goes off
ethan literally just i've seen this dude
like he backstabbed pewdiepie pewdiepie
helped him out a big time uh
there's this other uh big youtuber that
i can't think of at the
top of my head back stepping dude this
whole beef between oh he got me good
guys are you talking about himself
he's like there was another thing that
happened
it broke at their heart
yeah i know he he doesn't have the
courage to say his own name
you know
um
just a four-year-old guy talking about
using the word backstab unironically is
just embarrassing
to be honest
me and ethan klein started when i went
on his podcast everything was great um
you know great podcast great interaction
tell the story every time just five
years ago bro
this happened so long ago 2017. holy
[ __ ] bro move on leave me the [ __ ] alone
dude
goddamn oh i fly back home to buffalo go
bills uh i thought i come to buffalo
go bills
well he is on we're trying to suck up
support
yeah
um he leaves a comment and he's like i
[ __ ] hate keemstar on the video of
the podcast
after you just
yeah
that's not what i said
you guys know what i said he's talked
about this story a billion times
everyone knows the next day after i got
back god drive me crazy i he doesn't
like me either and that i everyone said
i was being okay this is what i was
saying i saw this clip and he says ethan
doesn't like me either and then in the
recent clip he says i don't know
anything about him who's ethan yeah i
mean why do people do that it's just
weird
we were dunking on recently who was like
very clearly pretending not to know who
you were and they were like who is it
etan
oh crowder
oh louder was the crowder crowder he was
like no there was someone else
who is this
no i remember that too who was it
i think it was portnoy we probably
talked about portland before maybe
listen
in the chat we'll know for sure give it
a second port noise
listen we can still be friends but you
gotta own up to that [ __ ]
copyright strike
that's whack dude
into like tourette's i think because he
has tourette's but he was making fun of
us
oh rolo tony tomas yeah rolly tony
browntown yeah what are you afraid of
ian yeah that guy thank you oh everybody
remembers everyone's typing
maybe they both did it at various times
browder didn't know how to pronounce
ethan right oh that's so funny crowder
come on you see me in your dreams said
how do you say ethan right
he feels like a common ass his name is
such a common name so [ __ ] stupid bro
bro you dream of me you have nightmares
where you're running for me in a hallway
well what a [ __ ] nightmare
rollo tony browntown
check yourself right out the door
you know you want some rolos
anyway
we can still be friends dave i don't
hate you but you pulled some whack [ __ ]
on me bro today
and i did say it's like it's tough to
make fun of somebody when you're
stuttering
no you said you said you said it was
it's tough to call someone a creep when
you have an eye twitch like that yeah
i just knew this guy's like out of the
clouds making fun of me like i'm gonna
make fun of you back dude it's fine i'm
not mad about that
it's fine
that's water under the bridge davey boy
davey my boy my bestie
all you got to do is own up to the
copyright [ __ ]
and we can be homies
grab a beer
watch some sparks go socks
what's that game he likes basketball
go south
[ __ ] pads dude go pads go [ __ ]
pads dude we'll have a cup of beers go
go to gillette stadium you gotta drink
high noon with him that's his thing now
high noon
i can't drink like him
i wish i could it'd be fun but
i just can't drink anymore like i cannot
drink dude it ruins my whole week it's
crazy
it's a good problem to have
it is yeah it is but sometimes you wish
that you could because sometimes people
drink and it looks like they're having
so much fun
sure they're having so much fun we are
yeah
yeah
but it's the [ __ ] after
it's the hangover it's the spins after
that just like
you got to be diligent about it
can you imagine if i was drinking though
my health yep
what do you mean diligent yeah what do
you mean by diligent uh drink pedialyte
that's really helpful like hydrating
hydration
we could actually know your limits we
could ask dr ids
but you know what it is in the lobby
it's not even the hangover it's when i
get drunk i don't feel good anymore is
it growing it doesn't feel like fun
you like it
well you still like it yeah
i'm gonna go rip it down it got to do
with my medicines yeah probably
saying he's recently talking about my
new girlfriend and he does this like
little skit where like my girlfriend
calls in the show it's obviously not my
girlfriend but it's a skit right
and uh they're talking about how i have
a little dick and my dick doesn't work
and all sounds pretty funny sounds like
a funny ass sketch
by the way he got us a strike for that
he bitched out yeah that one
sounds pretty good though it sounds like
a good show it puts some production
value some planning who are they
what's the name of that show oh so
they're [ __ ] i'm like what kind of
[ __ ] projection is this ethan klein
from the h3h3 podcast literally told the
world on his podcast that because he's
on anti-depression medicine that his
dick doesn't work it literally doesn't
like well we need a compilation of him
saying that on all the different shows
he goes on it's [ __ ] incredible this
man is obsessed with my penis function
hi i'm dick and it's just weird that he
thinks that's an own like you're talking
about a medical side effect
first of all my penis works just for i
keep saying that but
yeah thank you
it's just so it's just a loss of
sensation you know right uh but
it's so embarrassing that he's like yo
this idiot's on anti-depressants
and he got ed
what a loser that gets my dick hard
what is this so
it's such a different world i didn't
even know who he was until yeah like he
attacked the front of me
yeah and that's done right yeah because
teresha left because ethan kind of drove
her to leave i think now how am i the
bad guy
they're in this like crazy world where i
drove trisha to leave you know i'm
bullying keemstar keemstar is the poor
victim of me
what a what a wait universe a second ago
when they when keem said uh that you
backstabbed trisha didn't they literally
say oh really ethan not trisha yes they
did that's a good meme that's a good
observation
just saying how are you gonna be
how are you gonna how's that the summary
of the end of frenemies
uh yeah and that's done right yeah
because teresha left because ethan kind
of drove her to leave i think
that's some [ __ ]
and you can at least say it's
complicated okay except that that's
what i'll accept but it's a tangled web
yeah
and that yeah it can only survive that
type of dynamic so long yeah that was
that was a brutal dynamic honestly it
was a crazy one all right dude i look
there's such good is such good
commentary from them bro josh richards
he's so dope
he's actually so dope and insightful
some say the dopest wait just watch the
commentary and this is really good
brutal dynamic honestly it was a crazy
one that was crazy bro
josh man man
he's on his phone i'm pretty sure josh
man he's socrates level
that was crazy that story's crazy though
that was crazy
but that was nuts dead wild days
dude that was nuts dude you're going off
right now right holy [ __ ] man you're so
right i was crazy
that was a brutal type
it was a crazy one all right
crazy man i'm just taking my bong rip
real quick dude
yo i recently said something that i
thought was uh very credible um she was
on tanner's podcast and i listened to
this episode and she said listen the
reason why frenemies really ended
up
me and uh she said me and ethan we got
all these fights and we broke up like so
many times but they were all my fault so
i could like come back and like you know
apologize and things could be fine the
last time they fought was literally
ethan's fault he started it and he
couldn't acknowledge it he couldn't
accept it so there was no mending in the
relationship and i thought that was dead
on right
you know what's funny about this he's
talking to them like they have this
intimate knowledge of my person of who i
am right like bro nobody is obsessed
with me like you like
they don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about it's embarrassing to keep
bringing up my ed what are they supposed
to say about that
i don't have ed
okay
thank you
and even if i did i don't give i really
don't care
because my mental health is more
important
yeah it's straight back bro
yeah that shit's crazy
that shit's crazy you're spitting yeah
oh it's wild dude
that's crazy man man
that [ __ ] is crazy wow dude
man it's wednesday my dj it is wednesday
it's crazy oh man [ __ ]
all right we we got poor doctor ids on
the line yeah talking about drinking
yeah yeah yeah
if
coke is healthier than piss
all right stand by and bring them in
stand by
keep
doctor here he is
welcome back to the show
how are you my friend how's it going
doctor thank you for joining us on such
a short notice obviously we wouldn't
invite you on like this unless it was
something urgent
and uh
pressing
so dr um
i don't know if you're aware there's a
community of people that drink their own
urine
some ferment it they bottle it some
drink it fresh
they say they're recouping their bodies
uh beautiful wonderful vitamins
is this a good idea doctor
right um
okay so we need to
need to be careful about how we address
this because uh
you know i am aware that it is part of
some cultural norms and it is actually
part of some society's practices
right um but at the same time i think
this this practice might have been
kind of made pretty popular or at least
known of in the west
from
i think it was um
is it armstrong or someone someone
basically wrote a book
claiming that drinking your urine is
like
what was it like the treat like um
the treasure within urine or something
like that or something like that about
50 60 years ago
and he was claiming that
drinking your urine cures heart problems
um
pink your cancer wow
you know even allergic conditions that
your you know people are born with it's
amazing
yeah so
you know i think uh a lot of these
claims have actually been blown out of
proportion massively
and
people need to realize that
you know urine does contain lots of
pathogens meaning it contains lots of
bacteria
lots of toxins
and even if you don't have a urinary
tract infection meaning you're not you
don't have an acute infection in your
urine
but that isn't the same as not having
any bacteria in your urine right right
so essentially what i'm saying is is
that we have lots of
millions and millions of bacteria just
living just you know they're living
happily within our body
right whether it's in the gut in the
urine in our mouth
in our you know anywhere along our
digestive tract on our skin we have
millions of bacteria on our skin as well
they live
perfectly happy
now
when you cause
an imbalance
an overgrowth
or you cause some change in the number
of bacteria you have right so imagine
you take that urine
and then you swallow it so what you're
doing is you're introducing millions of
well not millions but loads of bacteria
that shouldn't be there in the places
in which you're consuming them right so
in your mouth you've got you know a good
set number of organisms living happily
they're all swimming around doing their
own thing right and then you take the
happy organisms in your urine and within
your tubes where you pee out of
and you introduce them to somewhere
where it's no longer going to be happy
then you cause an imbalance and you run
the risk of you know getting e coli
infections you know and i've seen this
in a hospital lots of times
it's it's real bad it's real bad because
doctor can i ask you a question um
there's another thing involving urine uh
peeing in the butt is that a health
concern or do you think that's fine
you pee in another person's butt
why would someone do that
uh piss in my ass [ __ ] that's white
claw game yeah because it's friday
because it's friday
yeah it's because it's friday it's
friday it's a sexual act you know oh
okay
um so a similar thing applies so we
don't like doing it
no we don't like it because you're
causing an imbalance in the environment
which is living happily you got it
right so we say no say no
to uh consuming urine and it's a section
and what about these people have you
seen these where they ferment it they
can it for like months and months
what's it supposed to do like like age
like fine wine yes i don't understand
is it oh okay so gnarly they make a lot
of claims about all kinds of uh um
health benefits to it in fact
one clip so this was the um the person i
was talking about earlier who oh yeah
this guy yeah so doctor here's a little
fresh little clip for you here go on
then let's
[Music]
see it's human juice
it's human juice
just having my midstream i pissed the
first part usually i do the whole thing
but i don't feel like eating or drinking
that much urine just a little bit i just
flooded my body with superfoods and i
shawn my scrotum with uh 660 nanometer
wavelength as well as 850 getting right
into those spermatic cells really
secreting good and all right
are you catching all that it's a lot of
yeah so he shot he's he's shining light
on his scrotum as well yes that's right
yeah at a certain wavelength though 660
i believe yeah and and why is he saying
he's doing that
well let's go maybe it's like an angel
number or something
maybe it's like good luck okay let's see
let's see
uh you know i find it so much easier to
feel authentic when my glandular system
is potent and so i'm gonna drink my piss
to reabsorb
all those expensive organic superfoods
it's a cost-saving measure
right
he's getting the best bang for his buck
there on those expensive
superfoods
you know the funny thing about about the
shining the light on the scrotum bit is
actually
the scrotum is hidden from sunlight for
a reason
that's what i thought i remember when
this was popping up i was so confused i
thought the whole point is so we keep it
away we keep those we keep the scrotum
out of the sun
yes because the skin is very fragile
very thin
it's not designed it's not part of our
design to have it exposed to
light or heat
so
actually you know you you're running the
risk of causing you know genetic
mutations in those cells really
yeah
wow crazy
so you could be actually
you could be when you really
the really sad thing is is that if you
start to develop a skin cancer on that
area because every day you're doing what
this person is saying to do
then you're not going to be able to see
it
right right because it's cause it's the
scrub
yeah and when you get a stage four skin
cancer you're pretty much fried it's
very hard like it's very easy to treat
early on
and it has a very good you know success
rate early on but who's looking down
there every day like and and even those
who are looking down there who knows
what they're looking for probably not
that huh
yeah no one
so
don't do that
is stage four is like stage three for
skin cancer i'm just asking my own i'm
just curious does it look like super
[ __ ] up like it's hard to miss
no it's not advanced
it no it's not really about the look
it's more about the depth into the skin
okay um so you know the typical skin
cancer that you guys are probably
familiar with is the you know the black
kind of pigmented
you know
malignant melanoma we call it right but
you have lots of different types of skin
cancer that are actually colorless they
might be pink they might be the same as
your skin tone
they might be a little circle they might
be a thin spread skin cancer
so the typical ones that you see on tv
or you know you see on the news or
whatever they will be you know the barn
door in your face kind of black weird
kind of pigmented you know skin cancers
those ones are easily identifiable um
they can develop from any mole you know
if you guys have moles if they're
rapidly changing you should get them
checked
yeah we had a whole thing about that but
what do we do about the pink ones or
this color of your skin what do we do
about that
well a general
a general guide is
if you see any lump bump or skin lesion
okay that is changing in size
changing in elevation
changing in the rim so the actual the
texture of the rim and the shape of the
rim
and if it's asymmetrical in color so
it's not the same color throughout
then those are guidelines to go and get
it checked out by a doctor so you it'll
be it'll be like bumpy
if you have it
yeah so bumpy is one of them it doesn't
have to be bumpy you can have ones that
are completely flat against the skin you
don't actually feel anything you don't
feel anything
yeah there are some way you don't feel
anything
yeah so what how what would how would
you catch that one
so different colors
or if it's you know if there's like a
ring around it like a different shape
ring okay okay so maybe on one side it's
one shape on the other side so you would
me it wouldn't be bumpy but it would
have some visible
you will have one of the four or five
characteristics that i've described
yeah so either texture color
asymmetry elevation of the skin yeah now
um i have a question for you i have a
friend who had a really weird looking
mole on the back of his neck
it was just the border was super weird
and it was really dark
and i said to him yo you should get that
checked out
and he went to the doctor
and um
it was benign and now he's angry at me
do you think that's right
absolutely not right absolutely not
because you can have
yeah you did good you did good tell your
friends because thank you so much
because lots of people with white skin
caucasian background
you can have 20 30 50 moles
on your skin right it only takes one to
be
a non-benign lesion
and if you keep saying oh it's probably
just another one that's growing or
whatever whenever you see change get it
checked
that's it so
can you send this i'm going to say can
you send this to the doctor i want to
know if i have skin cancer
well
yeah
doctor
i mean i won't be able to formally
diagnose anything but i can give you i
can give you advice
i can just give you advice just to say
you know if it looks concerning to get
it checked out
yeah so loris
how am i gonna see this where am i where
am i looking i'll i'll send it to you
okay i guess olivia's going to send it
to you
i got a good photo here okay
hang on doctor we got uh anyone else
want something they need diagnosed
since we got a doctor on the line yeah
like i can give general
guidance health guidance like i'm not
diagnosed we're looking for official
diagnosis
[Laughter]
yes are you able to are you able to
uh write scripts over this
i'm sure we could get you some kind of
permit or something so you could write
us a script overseas
yeah or maybe you could just grab them
and i could just reimburse it you could
ship it
yeah just really do this
just kidding just kidding just i know
this isn't even funny you're a real
doctor we don't joke about these things
yes thank you ethan for waiting no no we
don't joke about this did you send it
yes okay so this is a bump
it's been on my leg for
a year plus you know
it's where am i looking where am i
looking
i just sent it to you so it should pop
up okay
yeah you could pull up the photo too dan
so the people at home can you send it in
okay yeah you got it uh
okay yeah so it's a it's a red bump
and it's i've had it for a year plus it
doesn't really changed much but it's
very um hard to touch
yeah interesting so it's been there for
a year yeah at least at least
right
okay and what when did you first notice
it what what was it looking like that
picture
and it was basically i noticed it like
that it was like this hard kind of
growth that just came out
on my leg and if you guys are wondering
where that is it's my
calf basically
yeah
so okay so you noticed it basically
looking like that yeah
and that was about a year ago
at least
okay so if we apply the general tips
that i gave earlier
you guys should remember them by now so
go on you guys tell me well there's the
color even it's lumpy even and is the
border blurred yeah i don't think so the
border looks fine
right
it's you guys are good there's a uniform
color right yeah i think you're okay it
kind of
what are the what were the other ones
scabby
so elevated so is it elevated
it is elevated yeah that's fine but has
the elevation changed no
is it growing further out no
no okay fine is there there's no kind of
hard and fast you know border like you
couldn't draw a circle around it
properly
like there's no rigid kind of mark
around the end it doesn't look like
anyway it looks like it's black i guess
i don't know what that means but no i
don't think so
basically like you you've got a circle
or you've got like a faded kind of shade
of color like it fades into yourself
which is the bad one
basically like a circle like a dot like
oh okay a well-defined no no we don't
have a high contrast between the we have
a healthy fade we have a healthy fade
okay so there's a good skin fade there
and by the way your fade looks fresh as
hell i want to tell you
yeah i had it a couple days ago thanks
yeah it looks great
i had to cheer myself up before this 14
hour shift i just finished oh my
goodness and then you get on with us the
work never ends
i read the email like all right go on
then why not
was that drinking pee yeah
[Laughter]
yes so
so going back to this right
so applying the general principles that
are good for anyone to follow
this to me doesn't look too concerning
seeing as though there's not been too
much change over the past year
right
but if you still if you are particularly
concerned about there is no reason why
you can't get it looked at
but i'm i'm pretty sure hit the symbol
he says the verdict is
you should be okay
well doctor you'd be happy to know i
have showed it to a dermatologist you
said it's fine
good that was i was testing you
even though even though dermatology is
not my specialty i mean i sure like to
think i have some basic principles that
i can advise the problem no it's good
this is all we're saving lives here
today doctor but i'll say um
sometimes i wonder i was like man this
what if he's wrong
you know
god damn because he looked at it for a
second he's like oh that's just uh and
he gave me some medical term he's like
that's just uh
i was like okay
okay i'm not sure what that medical term
was but it sounded okay
[Laughter]
anyway doctor i think we saved lives
today here
no we did we did some good uh public
health service there we'll keep we'll
we'll keep it up this is important stuff
we gotta keep my fam my fans alive and
well okay we can't afford to lose any of
them
that's that's the purpose of what i do
every day my friend i try
if if if you guys can help facilitate
more improvement in health then i'm
happy love that
wait hold on howie has something to say
about this
my friend ethan bent over and this
happened oh i see i i got scared you
were about to show him the prolapsed
animals and without any gosh
even the doctor i went through that yeah
dr heads on tick tock you can find him
everywhere he's the legendary world
famous
dr higgs
friend of the show
all right get some sleep doctor you've
had a long day thank you so much thank
you my friend
and uh if you need me to debate any
doctors let me know yeah i will
absolutely for sure all right take care
take care dr ladies and gentlemen
says i do not have cancer
and do not drink urine
we're learning a lot or don't pee in the
butt either sorry gabe all good tips
sorry to burst the bubble on that one
buddy
[ __ ]
[Music]
there's one other thing i wanted to show
yeah go ahead just while we're between
topics uh some donors a hundred euros
from okay sin uh cinnamon
think of a gift
to dan for doing your job i always envy
you now i gotta give dan 100 is that for
you
no i think it's just addressed to me
well then to dan to dan isn't that 100
for you
i mean
if you want i mean so i could give you
100 and i got and i owe a little i
wasn't interpreting it that way it just
seemed like a it was a dream thank you
for the gifted
i think the gifted
but thank you thank you so much
and thank you for the 10 gifted sub
prolapse penguin
i'm h31
what's up dude
prolapsed
penguin thank you for the 10 gifted
yeah so while we're on the topic of uh
keemstar
lightly touched on trisha
here's a clip
i actually don't even know where it's
from where's this from
does anyone have intel on that
well whatever here it is
i know there's 196 people watching so
this is a worldwide proclamation well
when that baby uh comes out and things
uh calm down a little bit there will be
content with me and trisha paytas
are you the father
no
i am not
i mean i made a whole video about
yeah so
i i i don't i frankly don't believe it
that would be an insane thing to do for
trisha and i'm not i'm not gonna even
say that she'd said anything like that
uh because i don't believe him if it
happens if it actually happens then we
can talk about it you know what i mean
but
at this point i think it's just another
whack ass keemstar bait team star shut
up
also by the way didn't like the joke
about are you the father very corny
tasteless you know like what the [ __ ]
it's not funny
so
some yeah he's manifesting that's what
he's trying to do
god that would be honestly i wouldn't
even be super mad if they did make a
podcast because it would be such a train
wreck
um
it would be kind of fascinating to watch
it go down
it's like bro you're so don't you see
how obsessed you are with me now you're
trying to get to start a podcast with
trisha it's weird
like
realize
you want to live in my skin at this
point
damn
disturbed
so that's that now we got okay
we talked about pork boy
talked about
keem this is when it really goes down
and this one is going out to you love
you know
this this is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and i
feel like you even maybe were softer on
aiden ross than we were oh yeah
definitely did this break your heart
when you saw it
no because he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] bro i
don't give a [ __ ] what any things
he if i he talk [ __ ] on my [ __ ] five
dollar glasses and a ten dollar hat well
is it gonna hurt my feelings no not
really he came after love which you know
i mean who does that
uh let's watch aiden ross is looking for
some heat um and he's gonna get it
yes
andrew tate on aiden ross is this worth
talking about um
honestly i found it disappointing it was
just
what the [ __ ] is this man his usual
the the shtick is like i know people
think he's hilarious but like you know
what i realized
his whole like shtick now is just doing
uh do you remember maddox
yeah back in the day yeah he's just like
that but unironically right and it but
it's like so like early 2000s humor
[ __ ] hate kids i'll kick kids bro
kids are [ __ ] i get my energy from
the sun because i'm a man absorb rays
from the sun yeah yeah but it's not did
i just don't understand why
yeah so adam ross did this stream he had
like 230 000
viewers which is pretty nuts
uh with peace and love to aiden ross i
thought his interviewing was horrible i
mean i mean with his love is just kind
of i mean i'm not an interviewer bro i
mean he's not a six-year-old grey-haired
man
okay yeah
fair won't even object to that one he
didn't call me fat
he's not so i mean i don't really have
you know much you know not like me yeah
that's fair you don't have a lot of
experience i get it
i mean you're 60 years old with gray
hair i mean you should be better here
interviewing the media yeah that's fair
honestly i mean i do mean that okay
you've gotten good have you seen my bill
burr interview i'm not talking about
that one
i'm talking about in the last couple
years where are you
i'm out bro 30 minutes bro no
okay
but i just don't know why people are uh
celebrating he's getting so much
exposure recently bro andrew t is a
demon out of a one
interesting commentary
okay
don't disagree scary violence beating
the [ __ ] out of a woman it was just
raided by the police for kidnapping and
human trafficking i just don't
understand why people go like he's
entertaining i want to talk to him
and like dude what are you doing
promoting this guy he's a [ __ ]
psycho i don't think it's like
no comment from him on this one by the
way
i love that
he's like damn bro i'm not going to say
[ __ ] about this
i don't think it's yet widespread
knowledge of what
uh he just smiled he actually is though
i think he's really popular on tick tock
and it's just like these gu it's like
alex jones i i liken it to the alex
jones thing we're like all right i'm
going to be honest we're not watching
this i can't i can't
awesome he has the debate skills of
andrew tate himself
listen why did you pull it up if you
weren't going to engage with with what i
said
said he beats women up it's on video and
he's human trafficker so
do you want to comment on that
bro i can't bro i can't bro like bro
bro bro i can't
here bro what the [ __ ] oh hell no
[ __ ] outta here bro all right you didn't
say anything what the [ __ ] keep watching
i know i know but i'm saying like dude
you just played a clip of me
very
i think
accurately
criticizing you and you literally had
nothing to say i mean
l
okay
[ __ ] l lord aiden l ross
uh whoever requests that is so weird
y'all are trolls bro oh
oh man
he knows he's [ __ ]
he looks dumb as hell
see this is the type of joint you got to
dedicate to somebody just make sure that
that's best somebody
young money you know that's from
yeah the whole stick that aiden's doing
with him
wait why is he back on it young money
you know what that's from
that's my favorite i'm sorry but this is
just not seem entertaining to me i know
i'm like six-year-olds with gray hair
but i don't [ __ ] get why people watch
this
maybe i'm a boomer am i boomer love is
this entertaining
he really loses his like all his views
when he just do these kinds of streams
okay okay and then when he does actual
events they go up which is fair enough
but okay just him is not entertaining at
all it's what what you're seeing right
now is what you get okay okay so so so
these streams get less views and then
the big ones oh yeah all the crazy
numbers
yeah interesting is really [ __ ] up
it's so weird yeah
yeah again i feel like ayden's just
involved in something that has no idea
what he's doing you know he's trying to
stick but doesn't realize the
significance same thing with the whole
stake situation
yeah and i'ma keep [ __ ] gambling and
printing [ __ ] yeah obviously but you
cried to me when you talked to me did
you forget how you cried and begged for
forgiveness and said you were gonna stop
and now you're gonna call me out and say
i'm a [ __ ]
bro
i know you are i know you didn't stop
you literally admit that you know it's
[ __ ] up and then you kept doing it
and now i'm the [ __ ] and you're going
to keep doing it
dub
[ __ ]
dub
[ __ ] dude
and you were crying
i'm so sorry
daddy please
aiden loss
same thing with the whole steak
situation egg yeah and i'ma keep [ __ ]
gambling and printing [ __ ]
hell yeah
that's so good exactly he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's just just
and i did very damn i don't give a [ __ ]
or at least except when last time you
talked to me and you were crying please
i'm not gonna do it much longer i
promise
i think twitch should do something about
it because they're not going to dude
heidi ross is 21 years old he's damn bro
this is [ __ ] ugly ass cowboy [ __ ]
like have a a bone over me bro like what
the [ __ ]
like bro i don't understand like why are
these why are these dumb [ __ ] on my
dick bro like bro why are you on my we
just said that pretty thoroughly
well and also love was just saying
twitch should handle it yeah i wasn't
even really criticizing yeah i feel very
targeted here it's funny it's so funny
to me that he unleashes on love after
looking at all of us and you well he's
really
insecure when he saw my 10 hat you know
yeah dude he saw
he saw what a real man looks like and he
got [ __ ] scared yeah
yeah so this is when he goes off on love
that's when it goes sideways or at least
i think twitch should do something about
it because they're not going to dude
ross is 21 years old he's damn bro like
this is [ __ ] ugly ass cowboy [ __ ]
like have a uh a bone over me bro take
it back [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] about love that got
me defensive dude i was like hell no
really talking [ __ ] about love
having a little fun with some props
i can't believe it your whole life's a
prop bro
damn i've said it better myself i know
i know it just blew your mind [ __ ]
[ __ ] i got it i got it we were joking
about this before the show that it's
really good that he thought love was a
real cowboy that's going to help her his
immigration
he's america passing yeah exactly
yeah yeah hey bro i don't understand
like why these why are these dumb [ __ ]
on my dick bro like bro why are you on
my dick look at your room bro
okay that's when you [ __ ] up
dude isn't it is famous for having the
most [ __ ] up room in the game
like hold on just look here yeah pull it
up i mean first of all this is a
love has pulled an image this man was
living in a
dirty laundry infested the [ __ ] guy
has a curtain duct taped over the window
and you lit you could call out love's
room
beautiful backlit well-organized king
nice gradient i have my teddy fresh
right here oh you guys can't see it
because that's it
but dude hell no you didn't call out his
room
come on dog dude you're not even good at
flaming why why are you even on why are
you even an entertainer dude that's the
best you got yeah
come on like he everything he said is
like super just diminishable like he
called you 60 years old you're clearly
not 16. you're only 40. 36. exactly i'm
only 40 years old 37
talking [ __ ] about my hat my appearance
i mean that's some your room
yeah i played call of duty for a couple
you know growing up so this thing don't
don't touch me at all um
yeah you got to step it up to reach us
uh i mean at this point he probably
averages 20k juicers 20 20k viewers you
know that's like a third of us currently
which is kind of embarrassing doesn't
wait i thought he got way more than 20.
well on these average like streams you
know
that's crazy that when he doesn't have
like a sex offender or like a gambling
addict or somebody else crazy andrew had
230 000
that's so nuts yeah
why are these people on my nuts bro he's
always getting carried by by all these
people adam gets uh he gets like uh
pulled over for drunk driving why are
you always on my nuts why these police
on my nuts
they're not going to
he's probably right about that though
unfortunately [ __ ] the police no
no when he says they're not going to
twitch isn't going to be gambling yeah
dude makes two million dollars
a month with 20 000 live views
well he he like like he went for before
he went on a break here i see him like
his lower end streams when he's just
gaming it's like 20 average 25k average
then after the
what's what's his name uh um
interview the tape thing obviously like
spiked super much and he's been keeping
somewhat of a high average someone said
he's getting 70k now
yeah afterwards too
that's pretty good i understand why that
washes he's entertaining super smart
insightful
right on the nose every time bro i just
don't unders
like bro look look at it look at look
bro look how he's dressed like bro look
like
it's funny
no
aidan has no top sheet on his bed
bro you have no top sheet
i gotta find uh can you send me a
screenshot
yeah this man has no top sheet silence
bottom sheet blanket
grow up jail grow up
it's time to make your bed and go to
your room aiden ross and think about
what you've done i bet love has a great
bed
with a duvet cover is that right a top
sheet
bottom sheet
is that right you want to show your bed
or no
that would be the ultimate flex if
you're all set up there
uh i mean i'll show i have a i have a
both of those
things look at aidan's bed right there
i mean it's not [ __ ] small that room
looks like a room where
okay let's see let's see your bed
it's kind of bad i'm not gonna lie well
that's my bed right there it has a
bottom thing on it you know what i mean
you have a sheet on it and he's got a
headboard dude i have a headboard
back lights
is that laundry or just a blanket this
is some laundry right here you know okay
a little messy the finger in the middle
well he wasn't expecting company that
being said you do have a
bed sheet
yeah that's what that's the bottom line
right yeah bed sheet did you get a pick
for me
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
i was hoping somebody would pull the
pack of his sheetless mattress i'm
looking through
trying to find one where you can see it
clearly
well yeah i guess love has it because
he's using it as a background right now
here oh is that what you're talking
about this one yeah yeah
he does have a bed shoot on this one
um oh yeah that's true
he did laundry that day
yeah
shout out to the king
bed sheet
like it makes me mad bro [ __ ]
wearing sunglasses and a cowboy hat in a
[ __ ] room
stay mad
cope and see [ __ ] he's such a wait he
literally said
this
in a moment of rage this entertainer he
says this idiot is wearing a cowboy hat
and glasses
in a room
in a room [ __ ] roasted he literally
just did not wrap he just described
without without editorializing at all he
literally just described what he's
seeing
this guy is wearing a cowboy hat
glasses and he's sitting in a room
oh she that's a rose in my room how's
that a rose aidan i spy with my little
eye cowboy hat boy what else do you see
look at this guy with eyeballs man
yo this he's got a hair
yeah tell me what else you see buddy
keep it up you're doing good
like seriously bro
you're a dick rider you're a dick sucker
hop up my [ __ ] dick [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that's all he has that is
he says [ __ ] in a way yeah it's kind of
a chat yeah chat move pussyclap
pussycloth
[ __ ] that's all he's got as he says but
the funniest part of this clip is just
it's so
random and unwarranted i was kind of
like
i was defending him a little bit or
giving him the benefit of the doctor
more than anyone
boom
it's just i just find it very funny
[ __ ] is it interesting that
i mean you come from the twitch world
right before you
for us is it kind of interesting to be
specifically called out by aiden ross
yeah but i mean
honestly
it doesn't really
he's he's not on my radar really i don't
watch him at all bro you're sitting in a
room
shut up you're singing a room bro idiot
[ __ ] earphones and you're wearing a
beanie and a hoodie look at this girl
you got teeth and a nose two eyes and
two ears look at her look at her
look at her she has hair sitting in her
chair with a laptop in front of her look
at her the nerve
[ __ ] i know [ __ ]
hey bro you watch me bro you study me
you you look at my moves you watch my
every moves
of course you got a pokemane uh sticker
right there
[Laughter]
yeah
he noticed something interesting at
least
yeah but that was like damn calling that
out it's kind of too far in my opinion
you study his moves like cobra kai my
guy yeah yeah but i wonder if he's going
to uh
make some kind of commentary or if he's
just doing playing i spy he's like yo
you have a picture of pokemon because he
could be like yo of course you're simp
you dick right yeah
for ethan and pokey you know tier three
there's lots of different routes you
could take that
let's see if he does
i [ __ ] with pokey but of course oh yeah
and i like and i see that you do too
yeah
we have a lot in common bro
i think we could be dogs
damn
is that a face logo i [ __ ] with banks yo
i like banks bro
damn i don't give a [ __ ] bro
my thing is this bro stay in your own
lane stay in your own [ __ ] lane okay
why do people always tell other people
to stay in their lane or the big pieces
of [ __ ] that don't want anyone
criticizing them right
yeah it would be nice for you if
everybody stayed in their own lane quote
unquote whatever that means
you know
[ __ ] you know who you are you know who
i am cool h3 i know who you are
um i really don't got an issue with you
bro i think you're just too old to just
oh he just hates love yeah he just hates
me it's just love specifically oh okay
he's cool never take it all back here
i thought he was talking [ __ ] on me
just just me yeah
i think i wonder if like
me saying my age kind of triggered him
he's like oh he's on my playing field he
doesn't really want to [ __ ] with people
older than him who might have more
experience and like uh be able to [ __ ]
him up in a debate or whatever but oh
this guy is 21 the same age as me
that might have triggered something
within him to be fair my son's uh
vocal abc book could beat him in a
debate
yeah
i think he's just afraid of cowboys
cowboy phobia
yeah
cabobia
well
um i really don't got an issue with you
bro i think you're just too old to just
be hating and that's all that's all i'm
saying leaked footage of nene and his
girl
that could be that could be true it
could be too old to be hating it's fine
ain't gonna stop me though [ __ ]
what is this you sent ian
oh no aidan
h3 oh get ready to get on dude
are you ready no
it's a tick wait is that a storm a real
or it's a short oh it's a short
h33 you the worst podcast on youtube bro
[Laughter]
you have the worst podcast on youtube
bro you hate your life bro you literally
hate your life all you do is hate on
other people and put them wait where is
this from i didn't is this this is this
is juicy
this is fire
this is from the same stream
i'm not sure i saw it on reddit
when look at your own podcast it's
horrible nobody watches it it's boring i
watch
nobody like if you're going to insult me
at least like try harder you can't say
nobody watches it
that's just like i mean it's just not
true
you can't just say so it's like
come on
people a number 12 podcast in the world
hello hello
hello
hey dad
go to your [ __ ] room and put on a bed
sheet
h33
i'm putting it on i fell asleep oh god
oh my light bro your [ __ ] sucks bro it
sucks get some new guests on get some
[ __ ] [ __ ] on that [ __ ] you need
something oh my god
this is a lot you guys we should really
get some [ __ ] on this we need
something really nice he's spitting
facts
yo you know what we need [ __ ]
we need some hoes up in here have you uh
tried eating your boogers too i don't
know yeah we've done that that could be
yeah that that's a good suggestion
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
and on there i don't even know bro you
like retire bro at this point just
[ __ ] retire you suck your ass you
hate your life
my god 21 [ __ ] you h33
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
i think aiden learned
because
we gave him a little leeway because we
go well he's young and i was dumb at
that age i think he's leaning into that
too far now to be like i'm 21
bro cool
21 [ __ ] you
i mean and you will be forever aiden
what happened to the nice jewish good
boy
you hate
google it
i mean come on you know he's a good
jewish boy you know what i think it's
nice though that
he's doing some jewish representation in
popular media so many people hate jews
today
that um
he's doing he's
he's good he's out there
just stop with this you know
we also have some there's also bad jews
like harvey weinstein we're trying to
separate from that kind of [ __ ]
shout out to the woody allen jewish he's
jewish he's the most jewish shout out to
the good tribe that's not good the good
tribe
good part of the tribe
we don't want them
[ __ ]
[ __ ] there you have it i am roasted
owned next posted owned owned and
eviscerated by young and well loved
really took the brunt of that so yeah it
took took a major rule today right super
sorry about that
so [ __ ] about my background let's just
do farm
oh you know our new bestie friend of the
show mike
actually did a really good roast on um
aiden
place that with a smoke crack i'm not
even playing i'm not i'm dead [ __ ]
serious
yeah he says his room looks like a place
where he'd smoke crack and what's funny
about that is that it was even dirt it's
way messier and the one you have yeah
yeah yo is this one of the [ __ ]
sorry his words not mine
she looks beautiful and kind yeah she's
a sweetheart [ __ ]
[ __ ] and boogers
[ __ ] and boogers that's how you get
the views baby
that's so funny that's a good title love
that's fire
actually now we can end on a high note i
want to talk about alex jones we could
do it on wednesday it's just so good
sure it's a whole juicy thing and we're
coming up on a probably three hours now
but
we gotta celebrate our new best friend
ninja
[Music]
okay
now i don't know if you guys heard but
you guys were standing ninja pretty hard
on twitter
and then he reciprocated by
sending a [ __ ] load of g-fuel and not
only we got rare g-field too didn't we
we got like carbonated
ninja flavor canned g fuel hello yeah
that good can i get actually can i get
my own can i want to smash that right
now
i'll do both
i'll do both sam is uh our
sommelier
thank you uh yeah let me taste it
let me taste it and make sure it's it's
good vintage before you go
fermented enough
you've seen wine people they're so funny
they get their they literally do this
yeah that's nice
yeah it's part of the experience wait
before we drink this do we have approval
oh let me taste it first what
wait do we have approval though we don't
necessarily have permission wait what oh
from came from yeah right because flavor
the bubblegum flavor cotton candy
oh my god that is such a fine vintage
sam you can you can keep pouring thank
you
oh my god we'll accept the bottle
that tastes like heaven very good
does it taste even better because
ninja's name is attached
yeah right i gotta do that
gonna do a little
you gotta spit it out too that's what
the smallies do right i'm i know i'm
like a hater it's my thing but i don't
get the wine thing
i've tried
i want to get into it i've tried
expensive bottles it's in cheap bottles
you're just saying you don't like wine
in general i like wine but i'm saying
that oh it's all it's just i don't
believe in this
whole thing they taste how do you taste
wine and say it's nutty and fruity and
earthy it's like [ __ ] it's a grape too
much it's a grape
yeah you know what wine's made of a
grape
too much wine so all i could say is i've
seen those videos where people are
blindfolded and they're able to name
like 10 bottles in a row so i believe
that there is like a difference some
people do that horse light and bud light
and [ __ ] like that right exactly i just
know that i like it sour and a little
bit sweet
hmm
there it is there it is
you're my smallie
for real thank you hey ian show off your
um tumblr
oh wow ninja tumbler man
thank you so much sam is that the
metallica queen
i'm not the metallic they sent us three
different tumblers
yes so
this is apparently pretty rare it's
bottled and it has carbonation
really good stuff so the thing actually
what's interesting about this
[Music]
yeah i don't know if you guys remember
but keemstar had the cotton candy one
and then ninja got the cotton candy one
years after kim starr
was booted out of g fuel for being a
menace
and then he got mad at ninja for not
asking permission here but anyway we'll
get to that here's the unboxing what we
got here
cam how do you feel about the fuel i'm
so stoked i can't wait to drink it i'm a
slam tennis woman at once
and then
banks is feeling himself sword love over
here
here we go
[Music]
the ninja g fuel comes today it's gonna
get there before i get there they're
gonna open it and i'll have this awesome
bonding experience and i'm not gonna be
there because the traffic yeah is damn
[Music]
is this city also yeah
just
look at that
yeah they hooked it up fat more nina you
get a nina you get a nina wow that's a
lot of juice
watch this tastes like absolute [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
you need to leave
breakfast
sauce bro we got
there it is
the holy grail
i'm gonna wear this let's go
let's go
thank you nina for this bountiful
victory royale
this is an epic chug chug moment
and we appreciate you
and we will be celebrating in your honor
thank you
you're a [ __ ] loser
i missed it
damn
get [ __ ]
owned next
um
so that's pretty special i mean you guys
must be feeling really
really uh warm i mean incredibly gifted
taken care of yeah
ninja personally arranged this sure
i was kind of sad
yeah love fields i feel like you know we
can send you something extraordinaire i
feel a little bit left out wait for you
wait we can send you some you want this
well i don't want to cut into your
guys's profit i was thinking maybe do
you feel could you know
he's trying to get his own he's just
trying to get us oh you want your own
yeah yeah
i just want some my own juice you know
you want them to send you your own
personal pack
maybe yeah why why do you get your own
pack he's worth he's he's the true g
fuel head
among them show the closet
bro that shit's nuts love has like a g
fuel
i have everything bro love to introduce
the g fuel meta to the office too
you know i
i've been jews i probably spent a uh i
thought i thought away on g fuel damn
he's also the reason we all pronounce it
gee fuel or nina yeah like in a swedish
accent wait we should send him some cans
can we do that
international i don't from our stash
yeah no no see i don't want i don't want
to make create this i don't want to give
them up no i want to create this dynamic
for like you like stealing from your
guys's juice yes thank you i think you
may be entitled to it he's part of the
crew
i was thinking maybe we could get
reduced right
we can try and say hey yo we actually
have a guy in sweden i know it's nice
that you got you sent us that package
and all but can you please send another
package to sweden look how much brand
awareness we're giving them right now
you know
love this is for you they should be gone
thank you cameron
they should be paying us they can try to
send some but i don't know if it will
clear customs
[Music]
i've tried to send love stuff like that
before and they took it out of the box
yeah yeah they cut that [ __ ] open last
time
can't do it what about if we send you
powder do we get any powder
they sent us powder but not the ninja
flavor
i've had all the powder you guys got i
tried that okay player
yeah
oh yeah dan you got on for tonight too
man the whole ninja phenomenon is really
taking off dan refused to get the ninja
skin by the way i knew that was him
why didn't you get the ninja skin dan
well i just downloaded the game so i'm
not trying to drop a bunch of no excuses
but also aren't they like limited time
like yeah i don't think i could have
gotten if i wanted to
it's real it's all right i felt well
taken care of i was being protected by a
squad and ninjas yeah the blevins
brotherhood rolled in and we had your
back i can't see if i see myself or not
yeah we just missed that whole dance go
again
[Music]
ain't no not that one
turn that off
[Music]
did that ruin it for you
oh
man
well anyway listen we're our heart goes
out to keemstar
we know that the cotton candy
is his flavor
and uh ninja did not ever ask for
permission
so
even more he's gonna be even more upset
when he sees
what ninja just came out with yeah well
ninja says she said a big f you to
keemstar
we actually have a new trailer for his
flavor all right
go ahead
roll it exclusive
[Music]
laina olivia
sam zach young fika thank you for the
three gift of the bro
[Music]
hey b stock killer thing with the prime
ethan klein thank you for the five
dollar donut
[Music]
wow that was good that was good actually
i was super invent a creative yeah
good job cam i made ninja no that was g
full marketing team yeah shout out to
the g fuel marketing team
oh
[Music]
is there a lot of people playing as
ninja in fortnite
with that skin it's pretty rare only the
best yes
it is
i wonder if ninja plays his ninja
he does no okay good good thank you
i'm not as good if i play with other
skins actually
i have to stay on nina's skin
when when we were playing with dan we
got
four dubs in a row it's true is that
right four in a row your team won that's
a lot that's like pretty pretty
go ahead do it do it pick your mind
go around the game's for babies
it's a little it's a little baby game
it's very easy to win you win all the
time i kept telling them i'm gonna
download the game i'm gonna immediately
win and they kept saying shut the [ __ ]
up shut the [ __ ] up guess what happened
my very first game did he carry solo you
were playing bots dan doesn't matter i
got though you're playing bots let me
ask you something that's what they say i
don't know if that's true dan why did
you tell me this morning that yesterday
when you're playing on your own without
the ninja skin did you get any dubs or
i got lots of did you get no no did you
get any number yeah yeah i did i got a
victory royale yeah okay wait [ __ ]
nevermind did he have a did he carry the
team do you have a good kill death ratio
i don't think i carried
love is a big juicer so he was he was
probably the number one on the scene
dan's a gamer i held my own ian i'm a
gamer it's a game for babies it's
everybody who's playing is nine years
old and on an ipad it's like it's not
it's not that difficult to win did i
wish you could see the faces of your
opponents it's just a bunch of like
five-year-olds
in your [ __ ] face
[Music]
you heard it from dan fortnight is a
game for babies
that's fine i mean babies need games too
you know but i mean it isn't it's for
babies sam thoughts
i'm disgusted
[Laughter]
dan you better be winning every single
game if you think it's for babies
i mean some babies are good at videoing
well he will be for a while because it's
gilbert i know because you're in bot
mode right well i'm climbing the ladder
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
yeah yeah when you first start out
you're playing bots bro what the [ __ ]
are you bragging about winning against
boss well first of all i didn't know
that
eight seconds okay we'll take a step
back but second of all i wasn't reached
out i wasn't playing against bots when i
played yesterday and i was juicing boys
you played with them no but i played
again yesterday by myself and i was
juicing against bots it wasn't bots
that's what i'm saying i graduated out
of the box
okay all right all right baby i
graduated from bots to six-year-olds
i haven't played the bots are probably
better maybe i'll have to see for myself
i haven't played with dan yet
well you know what you guys play
together and then give me a report i'll
give you a report ethan when when are we
going to get you in dude you know what i
kind of want to try it
out dude
you guys play on pc
yeah it's crosstalk playing cross
platform yeah what do you guys play on
me and love are on pc can't or were you
on pc2 i was on pc okay i think just ian
plays on console sam you play pc and sam
no ps5
oh how do you play i don't understand
how can you play the same game
on ps5 and pc they give you a bunch of
aim assist
yeah because the keyboard and mouse is
way way better yeah but it balances out
pretty fair they've kind of figured that
out a lot of fps's do cross-platform now
and it's not really it's not really a
problem yeah
it's like
feels like aimbot
well it's not it's not aimbot but it
just does some some degree of aim assist
but
that used to be like taboo to let them
cross-pollinate but all the games do it
now and it honestly seems fine
interesting what were you saying love i
said it's not a problem for like low
casual players but when you get up for
the pros they like swap to a controller
when they have a sniper
and like really they use both
yeah some of them use both i've heard
yeah so they're like super sweaty
that seems like a whole thing
i gotta say dan is really good at
fortnite though i'm definitely by far
the worst in the office
damn sorry wait a minute against you cam
no don't
dance when you guys kill people you're a
gamer stop stop don't be so hard on
yourself well i play better when i play
with uh kind people come
all right well i'm always your spirit
for you yeah that's true
all right oh people want us to play a
member stream that's funny
fortnite member stream that'd be good
let's go
let's get it going let's just let me try
it though i'll try it in the next uh
next couple weeks here
anyway that's the show
um i hope you guys had fun
we are expecting an apology from dave
right dave portnoy it's not coming i
mean we
[Laughter]
well we proved that
we
we gave the receipts the evidence is all
there dave what's an apology
you're gonna strike two that's what
you're getting that's crazy bro oh
apologizing whoa
and then keemstar get off my can i say
get off my dick to keemstar just
probably not no no dick rider you're a
dick sucker hop off my [ __ ] dick
i'm 21. [ __ ] you maybe i'll just say hi
maybe that is a sound bite 21 [ __ ] you
maybe i say hi keemstar
thanks for watching
i'm also waiting for an apology from
aiden of course that's true we need a
paul yeah
yeah i'll have a little bit of my own
you know friendship tour maybe they're
not going to
yeah because i want to bury the hatchet
but these people are making a hard on me
you know we still can be friends aiden
and dave there's a there's a friendship
potential road
but uh
it's going to take some time
yeah for sure and uh shout out codekeem
on teddyfresh.com
does not work
thanks to elo
off it's 0
percent off
god came for zero percent off
well we'll be back on wednesday
yes we will and we've got
we have a lot of fun stuff even still
the alex jones stuff is just incredible
you guys i mean it's so good
yeah well uh actually speaking of pork
pork boy um we saw it right before the
show about having oh [ __ ] yeah uh look
into it
but just a little teaser some breaking
news thank you exactly
is uh he posted on his uh instagram
story that he was served papers for a
lawsuit related to safe moon yes and he
actually shows that um
it was keemstar daniel keem was also oh
my god listed on that lawsuit
as well as some other people so
everybody who was involved in
safe move
going to the moon is uh
wait hold on i've got
wait i totally forgot yeah this broke
right when we started
so keemstar is now being sued twice
once by
the safe moon [ __ ]
and the other one by deaf noodles
i was woken up today at 8 00 a.m by this
guy knocking on my door for 10 minutes
straight my dog was going crazy i
thought my house was on fire i told him
to wait so i could get my phone and
document it
dude you got served i just bought 39
million damn wait wait wait wait wait
wait why is he blasting this guy he's
just a [ __ ] he just he's just serving
the papers
yeah it's not really his fault yeah
he's doing his job the cliche messenger
yeah exactly literally shooting the
messenger oh you're a process server
yo process these nuts
yo
nope he was just telling me i was
getting sued for shilling safe mode
that's so awesome
wait did dave schill's
safe moon i don't remember dave being
involved
he probably did one of those tweets i i
don't know but i feel like so many
people did those yo i love how much he's
putting out there though i mean shout
the [ __ ] out that he put in
abe streaming
competing my response
trying to go to war he said the show
didn't even end and he's already
streaming well it says starting soon to
be fair
shameless
my response
whoa that title
oh do we think it's uh in reference to
the reddit post
that's what it means what read it post
what we talked about with him earlier
yeah oh yeah the response what do you
need to respond to everyone said you're
funny they're just [ __ ] on me bro
what do you need to respond to
clout god somebody says it's true we got
that clickbait
maybe the clown goblin no not not cloud
goblin clap god
dude here's your response raise your
voice a little bit that's it
all right
all right enough of that dan
okay
so um here's the lawsuit
can you is this a person that we know
christopher
this motherfucker's name is rocalcus
uh christopher
racaucus
well i imagine it's somebody who felt
victimized by the whole safe moon pump
and dump and they're probably suing a
bunch of influencers
they allege
ai science promoted it
whoa
oh mit
what are you reading an internet
software person
oh oh oh you found the christopher yeah
yeah so they're suing safe moon and dave
this is crazy mark
so right there look at the co-defendants
last name
on the list
this is the
yeah right there okay
safe moon
llc statement us safe moon connect
there's a bigger image the next one in
the gallery okay thank you
damn how many companies safemen have so
sketch they have like eight different
[ __ ] corpse
who's do we know who any of these other
people are braden john
carrone jack [ __ ] hanes davies
i know who these people are
jake paul's on here
dave portnoy
and daniel keem my man
you know what's crazy
when i type the name jack hanes davies
into google the
the first uh
google result is like a
scam alert website
i'm serious
offshore alert
class action lawsuit
fraud
um oops
so this is real interesting what's funny
about this is even if it's like a total
[ __ ] lawsuit
keemstar still has to respond he's
supposed to pay a lawyer and [ __ ]
that's the crazy thing keep in mind i
bought 40k of safeway myself and haven't
sold a penny it's worth this now 39
million
i'm surprised it's worth that much still
uh
yeah
i thought it'd be worth zero
yeah it's still around safe dude
look wait okay so he
has five million that's nothing
he only has five million safe moon
those are rookie numbers bro
my buddy has like 100 million he is down
95 percent is that critical and the
number so uh 91
well this is very interesting i'm
curious to see where this goes keep in
mind i was never paid a nickel to
promote safe boom i told people it could
be a scam when i invested i love to see
the video they play in court i believe
dave i don't think he ever promoted this
[ __ ]
keemstar on the other hand i'm not so
sure about
i'm no lawyer but it seems tough to
blame me when the first time i mentioned
it was may
17 and in vietnam that said invest to
your own risk i have no idea how this
works
fair enough he'll probably be fine he'll
be yeah totally fine
but but it's hard to i don't i think
this is an improper jointer which is
what kavkav tried to do to me that was
what it reminded me of when i saw that
how long of a list of names are there
to join this many people together you
have to prove that
that they're like in conspiracy together
or something i think
and there's no way that that
yeah this is all those parties are
working together yeah so they're gonna
have to they're probably gonna someone's
gonna get an attorney to get this thrown
out for improper jointer
somebody said y'all are narcs dude you
posted this on his own instagram wait
why are we knocking i don't know
[Music]
oh maybe they were talking about a b
because the chat did kind of gnark on
him that was well what were they saying
well they were all there was a bunch of
people saying ab you just went live on
twitch
funny
little cloudy boy though
y'all are
narcs
you're all about to get a b fire you
snitches av just texted us dude i legit
waited for you guys to say goodbye
before i started my stream
you know how this [ __ ] works you work
here ain't nobody say goodbye
goodbye doesn't mean goodbye here yeah
so true until you see that title card
yeah you have to see if there's still an
hour left sometimes
um
yeah so this is going to get thrown out
and then if they want to sue
they have to sue each person
individually which
is going to cost a lot more time and
money
so we'll see if they
refile it against these people
yeah but this is this is a pretty shitty
document
there you have it shout the [ __ ] out
safe moon going to the moon baby
all right well that is it now
a b the show is officially done
apparently he turned his stream off
again
[Laughter]
um
and uh
there you have it
so we'll see you guys on wednesday and
uh thank you everyone for watching
tata
love ya
see on wednesday
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you